as you walk down the halls of the SCP
Foundation site 19 peing in the various
windows at the anomalies contained there
you might catch a glimpse of a dark
figure bent over a table tinkering away
like an artisan in his Workshop a
vintage black Apothecary bag sits next
to him open and if you stop and watch
for a while you'll see him pull all
manner of tools out of it impossibly
large tools things that shouldn't fit in
such a small bag a bone saw an IV stand
jars of fluorescent liquids and needles
the length of your forearm you shouldn't
be surprised this is a place for
impossible things after all still it's a
curious sight the shadowy man working so
diligently so quietly Focus singularly
on his craft whatever that might be only
one thing could distract him from his
efforts you he feels your Gaze on him
and he looks up dark eyes glittering
from behind a beaked ceramic mask he
reminds you of an illustration you once
saw in a book about the Black Death the
gear of the plague doctors wore while
treating patients on their Death Beds
hello he greets you in a friendly
heavily accented voice his eyes crinkle
beneath the mask and if you could see
his mouth you know he'd be smiling how
are you today dear fellow are you
feeling quite well he takes a step
toward the window stretching out one
gloved hand and you suddenly realize
that you can't see where the mask ends
and his skin begins it's not a mask but
a part of his face this is no ordinary
man do you require help I can examine
you he offers Palm pressed flat against
the glass a chill runs up your spine and
you realize that you should definitely
not take him up on his offer no matter
how friendly he seems how good his
intentions may be you wouldn't want to
let the plague doctor treat you he sat
in his containment cell fidgeting with
his favorite scalpel he dragged it over
the surface of his workt back and forth
listening to the sound it made they had
tried to confiscate his table his tools
the guards had quickly learned that he
had more of them in his bag they tried
to take away his bag from him but well
that didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
Fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morg for
him to dissect and research there was a
time when the doctors here would come to
speak with him talking of cryobiology
and the pestilence he had dedicated
himself to fighting those days were long
gone he had hidden away pieces of the
corpses tissue samples and jars of
formaly he could pull out when the
monotony became too much but the days of
fresh materials of enlightened discourse
with other men and women of science were
over how he missed those days
the chance to work with others as he
once had what had he done wrong all he
did was treat the sick sure they didn't
always understand their illness didn't
want to receive their medicine but that
wasn't a choice for the patient to make
that should have been up to the
physician perhaps they didn't trust his
expertise didn't see how his work served
the greater good like those who watched
Yona Suk invent the polio vaccine or Lou
pasture rid milk of bacteria they were
confused by the advanced scientific
practices and feared that which they did
not understand he could forgive them for
their ignorance he was magnanimous that
way if only they would let him out of
this infernal room he could prove his
work's Worth to them he could cure them
all began a new era of wellness and
peace worldwide he didn't exactly sleep
but when he rested on his little cot in
the corner of the room he dreamed of
that future of a world healed by a touch
a knock at the door stirred him from his
Ry someone someone was at the door of
his containment cell he glanced at the
little window and saw a guard there with
a tray of food he greeted the man with
an enthusiastic wave sustenance he
didn't require the food for survival of
course but it helped his mind work more
efficiently it reminded him of a time
before these fluorescent lights and
these same Four Walls of crusty bread
with fresh butter by the banks of the
sin a little slot opened in the door and
the tray was shoved through there was
bread just as he hoped a small dish of
butter pot of jam and a cup of tea still
seeming he picked up the cup at first
taking a deep breath ah an herbal blend
with fresh lavender lovely he couldn't
see the guard through the window anymore
but he called out to him just the same
thank you for the Libations he still had
his manners after all even in
confinement he wished he could have
gotten a better look at the man seen the
poor of his complexion a Tremor in his
hand he thought he had spotted sweat
beating on his forehead could he be ill
the case required further examination to
be certain he sighed clutching the cup
of tea tighter in frustration why
wouldn't they just let him work why must
they scream at the sight of his efforts
flee from his instruments it didn't seem
fair still the pursuit of science rarely
was a glamorous one he had learned as
much over the centuries one day though
history would look back on him kindly of
this he could be certain he was just
settling in and beginning to spread
butter across the admittedly stale bread
when a horrible sound shook him to
attention he had heard the noise before
though he had never seen its source it
was an earsplitting scream a whale of
pure Agony like the sound of a wounded
wild animal he had heard many many
screams during his life from patience
and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into
cust custody of the foundation he had
never heard a scream quite like this one
it was pure rage Devastation and
suffering mixed together wet with tears
and loud enough to rip through human
vocal folds whatever was crying out it
was no mere man more screams answered it
and these were very much human these
sounds were more familiar to him shs of
pain of fear of desperate but futile
attempts to escape then the meaty thud
of bodies falling to the floor of torn
off limbs hitting walls and windows a
loud crash and the sound of something
large moving quite quickly through the
Halls scientific curiosity got the
better of the doctor and he found
himself moving back to his little window
face pressed to the glass so hard his
beak nearly cracked it he couldn't see
much of anything just guards running
down the hall weapons drawn he saw one
of them fire heard the gunshot ring out
but what was he firing at then he saw it
a pale blur darting past the door
whatever it was it didn't so much as
Flinch when the bullet ricocheted off
its skin a long thin arm crashed against
the door knocking the doctor backwards
into his workt he steadied himself and
climbed back to his feet taking in the
Damage Done to the door it was crumpled
in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it
was already gone from the sounds of
Chaos in the distance it had disappeared
around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of
the door to his containment cell it was
useless now hanging loose and open while
that was an invitation he was hardly
about to decline he grabbed his trusty
bag tossed his scalpel back inside and
set off to see what all the commotion
was it was easy enough to follow the
trail of blood Stark and Vivid red
against the white tile floor and the
sound of gunfire human screams and that
loud long painful whale he had heard
before he walked at a leisurely Pace
taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found
a mound of bodies guards and scientists
beaten and bloodied almost beyond
recognition it was quiet here save for
one sound the sound of weeping there in
the corner huddled over with its face to
the wall was a pale thin figure its
shoulders heaving with the force of its
sobs this poor soul was clearly in great
distress it was a peculiar sight
hairless and white extended arms wrapped
around itself as it cried excuse me the
doctor cried out to the pitiful creature
are you all right do you need assistance
it didn't answer it just continued to
cry had something so despondent been
responsible for this destruction the
dozens of corpses the smashed in walls
the crumbled doors and shattered Windows
it seemed impossible sure it was large
and looked strong but he had never seen
a monster cry before this couldn't be a
dangerous creature not when it was so
sad he would help it but first he would
attend to some of these bodies he sat
his bag on the ground and pulled out
several vials of liquid a set of
syringes and a variety of other surgical
tools he might need now after such a
long Hiatus he could resume his work in
a meaningful way he couldn't be certain
how long he worked Reviving these poor
souls and reconstructing their bodies as
the pale creature wept in the corner the
sobbing faded into the background for a
while becoming a kind of white noise as
he removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
One By One The Milky eyes fluttered open
riger mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion salow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over over the years he didn't
need to thank him with their words the
work was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature it didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the born man a vial
of thick black medicine give this to the
poor fellow in the corner please it
wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his Suffering
The Corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open an eyeball dangling unseen from
the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide imp possibly wide and it
Shri that same terrible sound as before
tears streamed from its colorless eyes
its arms shaking with unbridled rage as
its jaws locked around the patient's
head like a boa constrictor in one fluid
motion it swallowed the revived man hole
while the doctor watched in shock he had
been wrong this was not an innocent
creature caught in the wrong place at
the wrong time this creature whatever it
was was deeply sick
he had never seen such an advanced
aggressive case of the pestilence he'd
heard rumors of course but never
encountered it firsthand as a doctor he
had sworn to do no harm but in a drastic
situation drastic measures have to be
taken it was well known by himself and
the doctors at this Foundation that he
could cause any and all biological
functions in an organism to cease with a
single touch and so he approached the
creature arm outstretched ready to
administer that necessary touch to
protect the rest of his patience as he
approached the creature turned to him
its eyes wide and blank an endless
stream of Tears pouring from them
spilling onto the floor it shrieked
again mouth stretching wide enough to
engulf his entire head and ran toward
him at a Breakneck speed I am so sorry
you are not well the doctor said simply
as his hand pressed to the creature's
chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might
mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the Beast its eyes
closed its muscles went slack and it
collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thud the doctor paced around the Fallen
creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the
creature's chest still Rose and fell was
it his imagination he checked its pulse
and thought it was slow and faint and
though it was slow and faint it was very
much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased
curious very curious indeed he muttered
perhaps there were comorbidities present
other infections aside from the
pestilence which rendered the creature
unnaturally strong resilient to the
usual courses of treatment what would
cause these abilities this intense
aggression it seemed to be brought on
whenever someone looked at the entity's
face if only he studied Psych ology more
the science of the mind and its inner
workings since he had no experience with
therapy nor was he certain this creature
could communicate using language at all
there was only one way to find out more
about how this creature's brain worked
he would have to take it apart and see
for himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell he required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive Limbs and dragged the limp body
through the Halls once back in a famili
amiliar environment his worktable ready
and waiting the doctor instructed his
assistants to place the new patient on
the table it was a bit small unable to
accommodate the creatur's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official Foundation Laboratory he risked
Discovery and subsequent Interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an IV stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during during
surgery he could make the first incision
scalpel he held out a hand and his
favorite surgical blade was placed in it
by one of the helpful patience thank you
he slid the scalpel along the hairline
of the creature or where the hairline
would be if it weren't completely bald
once the scalp was removed he set it
aside for later when it could be
reattached Bona please he held out his
hand again and again his assistant gave
him the proper tool this however was
when things Scott strange the doctor had
always been a deaft hand at cutting he'd
once even received tutelage from the
great Robert Lon but no matter how hard
he tried to saw it never left a scratch
on the creature's skeleton naturally
this was somewhat frustrating he wanted
to study the creature's brain tissue to
get a sense for what was going up there
neurologically and he couldn't do that
if it was impossible to saw off the
creatur's cranial cap he blunted two of
his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he learned while studying the
ferary practices of the ancient
Egyptians he produced a long curved Hook
from his bag and inserted it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes doew all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place he was mid Stitch when a
voice interrupted his his careful work
nearly making him drop the needle hey
what are you doing he looked up to find
a guard aiming a gun at his face excuse
me I am in surgery at the moment please
do not interrupt he admonished the guard
but the man did not listen or lower his
weapon in fact he shouted something into
the radio code words the doctor didn't
recognize then he fired a bullet into
the skull of the patient standing at his
side how dare you the doctor cried
readying himself to confront the guard
but it was too late dozens of other
guards were swarming the room and
neutralizing his assistance some in
hazmat suits grabbed his arms and pulled
him away from the creature on the
operating table no matter how hard he
fought or how loudly he protested then
something incredible happened something
wonderful the creature opened its eyes
and sat up it looked directly at the
guard closest to it and the two saw one
another's faces the guard tensed
preparing preparing for the worst but
nothing came the creature simply stared
Placid and quiet no screaming no tearing
at flesh no mouth opening wider and
wider to swallow the manhole I did it
the doctor shouted overcome with Elation
I've cured you now Begins the rest of
your happy life he watched as the guards
led the shockingly calm creature away
back to its containment cell the
doctor's door was repaired and he was
returned to his state of captivity but
he never forgot the patient he helped
that day and how marvelous it felt to do
such a good deed meanwhile scp096 his
brain regrew within the hour and caused
another massive Containment Breach
murdering a variety of researchers and
guards but the staff agreed not to tell
SCP 049 about any of this better to just
let him have this one he really seemed
like he needed a win a very strange
anomaly sits in a humanoid containment
cell in the minimum security wing of
site 17
he walks talks and looks like a man but
everything else is convoluted in a
question mark this is SCP 343 who like
his Nam sake God is likely to cause
arguments whenever he's brought up is he
the creator of all that exists the basis
for the abrahamic faiths or is he a
pretender a reality warper with immense
power and predilection towards delusion
a courtesan of the House of madog
Matthew Methuselah Yahweh who knows
really it depends on who you ask and
which stories you choose to believe and
few people enjoy a good story more than
SCP 343 himself if one day you take the
time to visit him in his room and ask
him to reveal a page in the long book of
his personal history he might be kind
enough to tell you a story a story like
this of an encounter with something
monstrous that few others could hope to
survive meeting face to face rewind a
few thousand years nobody knows how many
exactly God as he chooses to dub himself
walked across the cracked ground on worn
sandals it'd been some time since he'd
seen an animal around here and even
longer since he'd seen a human being not
that this bothered him he'd never been
bothered by his own company on a long
walk like this of course he could have
sped up time or teleported but where was
the fun in that he was a tourist in the
world of sensation of experience of
Flesh bone dirt blood and Sand after all
where's the fun in creating a whole
universe if you can't drop in now and
then to visit and do as the Romans do
not that the Romans would be around for
another few thousand years even Atlas
must occasionally shift the weight of
the globe from his shoulders for a ja
around the cosmic neighborhood and
whatever passes for fresh air in the
vacuum God whistled a tune to himself it
was a craggy mountainous region he'd
found himself in the distant Peaks had
Frosted caps a breathtaking place where
many truly had their breaths taken away
how humans will so happily risk their
lives to do something extraordinary it
never ceased to amaze him his stomach
rumbled oh how he enjoyed that sensation
one of the funny little quirks of this
human form that he weaved for himself it
was no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
Friendly Village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a genial
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power God had always believe that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke Rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of The
Village's Town Square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some terrible
battle had occurred here but something
was wrong no bodies not one from
defender or a salent How could a
thriving Village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and depraved
that it left even God puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on Earth he didn't have access to True
omniscience How could a mere human mind
Bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body in its skull and leave it dribbling
out of his nose and ears instead he
chose to walk around the ruins of the
village and investigate firsthand arrows
and broken Spears and swords littered
the ground some buildings were
demolished but there were no tracks or
stray projectiles that could suggest the
presence of Siege weapons now these
buildings looked like they were ripped
apart some even still had claw marks
what terrible Beast could have set upon
this town and done this then he heard a
voice quiet and pleading beneath some
nearby rubble a Survivor he rushed over
to the pile and evaporated it with a
thought underneath a feeble old man
covered in stone dust was quivering God
helped him up and guided him into one of
the few remaining Huts still standing in
the village they both took seats God
held up two hands cradling empty space
two cups suddenly occupied that space
both filled with warm healing tea he
passed the old man one of the cups while
sipping from his own he asked the old
man if he'd seen what had happened the
old man told him no he hadn't seen
anything in decades he'd been rendered
blind in his youth little did either of
them know that very blindness was the
only reason he was the sole survivor of
the massacre the blind man told God that
one of the villages Scouts had gone up
into the mountain with a small Hunting
Party the group was gone for days until
one of the members the youngest among
them returned weeping frostbitten and
covered in blood he said that his
friends had been killed by a beast in
the mountains something that almost
looked like a man but terribly wrong and
its face it's awful awful face he would
never forget it he was just lucky to
escape with his life when the others
were torn apart but when the young man
returned he brought the shadow of death
with him it was a curse that doomed the
entire Village men wom and children to a
terrible fate and that fate was upon
them a mere hour after the Survivor had
returned of course there were gaps in
The Blind Man's understanding given he
was lacking one of his major senses but
the sounds he could describe with
perfect clarity it was faint and distant
at first that awful whale and the
Galloping hands and feet thundering
against the ground faster than any horse
could move getting closer and closer
another villager saw it approaching and
screamed then it was upon them the
Villager screamed but it screamed louder
always wailing and shrieking and sobbing
like a monster crawling Straight Up From
Hell people tried to fight it by the
sounds of it the blind man with teary
blank eyes recalled the sounds of arrows
knocking and swords clashing against
something but even their greatest
warriors had screamed and died those who
saw it and tried to flee and hide were
slaughtered all the same soon enough
there were only two sounds left in the
village the monster and the blind man
both weeping he didn't understand why it
never took him it wasn't fair it took
everything else to leave him here alive
when everyone and everything he'd ever
known was destroyed was a greater
punishment than even death after killing
all of these Innocents the monster had
simply wandered off to the mountains
again the sound of its quiet sobs
getting smaller and smaller until it was
gone altogether God comforted the blind
man as he wept for the loss of all his
loved ones he told the blind man that he
would venture up to the mountains
himself and confront the creature on its
own territory and at the very least find
out why it had done this terrible thing
but first he must relocate the blind man
to a safer place he placed a hand on the
Blind Man's shoulder and he vanished he
would appear in another Friendly Village
miles away God sent a silent message
into the minds of every villager take
take good care of this man he has
undergone Horrors you can't even imagine
your kindness will be rewarded later for
that you have my promise God sighed and
turned his tired eyes to the distant
mountains a monster lurked up there
perhaps one of his own Creations or
maybe a Corruption of one of his
Creations either way whatever existed
without his knowledge existed without
his consent and he intended to know of
the beast in the mountains though given
what he'd seen already he didn't expect
to receive a warm welcome from this
murderous demon miles away up in the
mountains the creature licked the blood
from its cracked lips it looked like it
might have once been a human being or
something that aspired to humanity or
mocked it with its very existence it was
a huge gangling Beast skin alablaster
eyes empty and soulless dribbling
rivulets of burning tears down a hideous
gaunt face he crawled into the Frozen
mouth of a cave with great icicle fangs
wheezing and weeping all it ever wanted
was to be alone why did they have to
keep interfering didn't they know what
happened all the terrible things they
made it do the creature curled its long
gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great ruts into the sides of
its bald Cranium with long sharp fingers
Terrible Things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised it turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with a kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes unwavering no no no no no
no he could feel it again the rage
bubbling up deep down down a cauldron of
seething anger it hated the feeling like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel he began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who I am the stranger
asked with a deep voice that betrayed
almost infinite power knowledge and
wisdom but it wouldn't change the
outcome here the monster bounded at him
at speeds that would wouldn't be seen
again until jet planes and bullet trains
are invented Millennia into the future
its jaws were hanging impossibly wide
fangs borne its arms extended and deadly
claws ready to strike but before those
terrible hands could close around the
stranger he vanished the monster
stumbled and rolled across the snow
confused what trickery was being used
here I'll take that as a no said the
voice from behind him you want to show
your father some respect more respect
than you gave to those poor people down
in the village at least seething the
creature turned and saw the stranger
standing back in the darkness of the
cave staring at him but the Beast didn't
have the capacity for awe or holy Terror
only violence boundless Limitless
Unstoppable violence it darted towards
the stranger again trying to strike him
somehow it was like fighting in an empty
robe not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the Str strer The
Stranger leaped backwards putting some
space between himself and the monster
but still not breaking a sweat he
breathed in deeply then exhaled the
breath came out like a mighty typhoon
shocking even the monster with its
sudden force it was blown backwards a
leaf in the wind until its Long Claws
dug into the ground and anchored it in
place the stranger gave a rise smile at
this impressed my my you're certainly a
tenacious one aren't you he said perhaps
we can talk for a little while instead
of fighting I want to know why you
killed all those people no answer the
Beast roared its Mighty limbs pounding
into the ground as it closed the gap
between itself and The Stranger in
fractions of a second it would kill him
Rend him destroy him just like all the
others he'd left it no choice suddenly
the ground below it seemed to give way
the creature was confused it looked down
to see that the ancient stone Below had
somehow taken on the properties of a
liquid and it was sinking the Beast
panicked and it began to thrash it was a
strong swimmer but it didn't expect to
need to swim here the shock was too much
and soon the ground submerged it
entirely muffling its terrible Roars and
shrieks and just like that the ground
was solid again trapping the Beast
inside the stranger stepped forward and
looked at the ground a much needed time
out he said you do yourself no good
struggling like this despite its
terrible capacity for evil God couldn't
help but admire the beast at least on
the level of construction it was so
paired down so unburdened a killer to
the core but seemingly unkillable had he
made this creature billions of species
and the species those in turn had
created through billions of years of
breeding and evolution and somewhere
along the line this thing happened it
was easy even for the universe's Creator
to lose track of some of the tinier
variables and in the grand scheme of
things even this monster was still a
tiny variable but right here right now
it was still one hell of a problem the
ground rumbled below God cracks formed
the mountain peak shook God raised an
eyebrow genuinely impressed as the
monster ripped free of its Stone prison
and re entered the fry it roared and
screamed still its blank eyes fixed on
him its skeletal body throbbed and
heaved with power unlike any other
creature in nature it was almost like
the longer their conflict went on the
more energized the Beast became God's
side all those poor villagers they never
stood a chance against this monster it
lunged for him even faster and stronger
than before he teleported out of the way
in the nick of time and the Beast claws
CLE through a nearby cave wall
effortless God materialized nearby but
he didn't have time to speak the Beast
lunged again and again and again every
time he reappeared the Beast went for
him with impossible speed deciding to
widen the playing field God teleported
to the top of the mountain the creature
somehow sensing his presence vaulted
upwards and tunneled through the roof of
the cave bursting out of the ground in
front of God who is floating just
slightly off the ground it would be wise
of you to stop God carefully in toned
all this time you know I've been going
easy on you you don't want to find out
what the wrath of God looks like storm
clouds were gathering above Mighty
Thunder roared across the sky the Beast
was undeterred it roared and galloped
towards God and God in turn called down
a response a volley of lightning the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or since struck down on the
charging monster the sudden white flash
could Sting the eyes from miles away the
monster shrieked from the blast feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and atomize
in the sheer heat of the electricity
around it it could smell itself cooking
the lightning blast only lasted for a
few seconds but for the Beast it felt
like eternity when the onslaught stopped
the air was still heavy with electrical
potential God stared down at the black
Scorch mark on the side of the mountain
where the creature had been standing all
the snow within a mile had been
evaporated by the blast it was a raw
display of the power of nature that
would make even Zeus tremble in his
sandals and yet there was still movement
something started to get up from the
burnt patch where nothing should be Left
Alive a blackened skeleton rising
shakily from the ash but still very much
alive as it started to Rise new flesh
began growing over its bones little by
little even God was astonished by the
side of it he'd never seen a creature
cling so ardently to life in spite of
having truly unsurmountable power
amassed against it it was up against God
and still it fought the monster tottered
on its freakishly long limbs still
disoriented unusually staggered for a
creature driven by such single-minded
violent purpose when enough of its face
grew back to do so it began to weep and
SOB again tears streaking down its
terrible face looking at this creature
after all of this God couldn't help but
feel a new emotion pity he lowered
himself to the ground and approached the
creature like none had ever done before
he gathered it up into his arms and he
held it feeling its heaving wretched
sobs against him the Beast was in so
much pain he could feel it radiating
from within speak my son God said in a
soft fatherly voice and for the first
and only time the monster spoke can look
can
see make me out people no wonder people
can look can look
please that was all it managed to choke
out before devolving back into
unintelligible Babble but it was enough
enough for God to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster 's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost Limitless
power to Grant it one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and God said
unto the Beast rest now child rest for
thousands of years if you must I hope
only that when you eventually awaken you
feel differently and so another story
from the C olog of SCP 343 of course it
leaves us with certain questions Chief
among them being is it true did 343 and
096 have this chance encounter long ago
or is this just another tall tale from
an anomaly who fancies himself a deity
we have our truth and you have yours let
us know what you believe Down Below in
the comments the day-to-day routine of
Dr gears consisted of a few constants
piping hot cups of black unsweet
sweetened coffee plain dry wheat toast
the soothing sounds of his favorite
white noise machine and the endless
Carousel of experiments with SCP 9914
not that he was complaining he was
perfectly content to spend his time
supervising one of the few anomalies he
crossed paths with on a regular basis
that was unlikely to kill or MIM him in
any way not that the Clockworks hadn't
produced its fair share of unpredictable
results over the years of extensive
testing it had definitely offered up
more than a few surprises and anyone who
knew Dr gears knew that he was not
especially fond of surprises Dr brght
had attempted to throw a surprise
birthday party for the man once but when
he turned on the lights and fired the
confetti cannon all Dr gears did in
response was give a deep sigh and say
really Jack you're making a spectacle of
yourself still he had resigned himself
long ago to the fact that supervising
the experiments with SCP 9914 meant
witnessing some truly unpredictable
outcomes how could he forget the time
researcher Blas tested an incandescent
light bulb on the setting very fine and
the Machine spat out an anthropomorphic
humanoid light bulb that spoke in German
accented English and claimed to be
Thomas Edison himself this was of course
impossible as historical records surely
would have indicated if Thomas Edison
was a walking talking light bulb rather
than a human man the impostor was
eventually incinerated after its
presence became too irritating to ignore
and then there was the time researcher
Thompson filled out a Dungeons and
Dragons character sheet and placed it
into the machine on the setting very
fine the outp produced was a sheet of
paper promoting the previously
non-existent tabletop roleplaying game
fear in the foundation whenever a person
read the paper they would suddenly find
themselves in an outof Body Experience
where they were inside the game's World
which contained several characters
related to the SCP Foundation as well as
items and locations based on real world
counterparts a subject in this state
would only snap back to reality after
winning or dying in the game researcher
Jacobson R all the one on stealth and
saw scp096 his face in the game and was
later found dead in the anomalous item
storage Wing there was no shortage of
foundation staff trying to use the
machine for personal gain too Dr naith
placed his credit card inside on the
setting very fine using it to produce a
card covered in unidentified corporate
insignias and reading rank Alf infinite
money privileges when Dr coldrain issued
a written warning Dr naith took that
warning and then placed it into the
machine on the same setting producing a
piece of official documentation from the
05 Council in support of his infinite
money privileges Junior researcher
Summers attempted to use SCP 914 in a
misguided attempt at self-improvement
placing not an object but herself in the
intake Booth before running the machine
on the setting very fine it cleared her
skin lengthened her hair hair and
improved her figure this was of course
in violation of several employee
guidelines and she was promptly
dismissed after emerging from SC SCP
9914 Dr Veritas left a note in the
experiment log following this incident
reading by the time we realized what she
was actually doing it was too late to
stop her needless to say she's since
been terminated and I hope I don't need
to tell you all not to do that again and
with that the guideline was clear no one
was permitted to use as CP 914 for
personal gain or to change anything
about themselves potential complications
were too risky not to mention the
conflicts of interest that would be
introduced into what should be an
impartial research process as scientific
objectivity biggest fan Dr gears
couldn't agree more so as he settled in
for the day's round of tests he intended
to keep a watchful eye on things and
ensure that no funny business would take
place he didn't have much reason for
concern as his colleague Dr Bonita
prepped her research materials she was
working with two items a small replica
of Michelangelo's sculpture of David and
a sealed envelope containing something
that was to be handled with Extreme
Caution a photograph of scp096 his face
she planned to place the items inside on
the very fine setting in an attempt to
see what result might be produced from
combining an ideal of traditional beauty
standards with the image of a creature
that felt such profound shame and
distress as its own appearance that it
would destroy anyone who looked at its
face like any good scientist Dr Bonita
wanted to remove any unnecessary
variables from her experiment so as she
placed her items inside the intake Booth
she slowly delicately unsealed the
envelope she wanted to put the picture
inside by itself without the extra
element of the envelope potentially
complicating things unfortunately like
Marie curri slowly intentionally
poisoning herself with her own research
materials she didn't truly understand
the danger of what she held in her hands
just as she was setting the photograph
down her eyes flickered to the image
before she could stop herself before she
could even look away or squeeze her eyes
shut she caught a glimpse of the one
thing she should never look at SCP
96's face she gasped and slammed the
photograph down but she knew it was too
late the sound of an inhuman sh coming
from across the facility signaled that
she was right it was coming for her and
nothing in the world could stopped in a
containment cell on the other side of
the facility Foundation staff were
horrified as they heard The Telltale
scream of an enraged scp096 the pale
thin creature once huddled in the corner
silently had stretched to its full
height of 2.38 M and was screaming
sobbing wailing and gibberish and
beginning to tear its way out of the
chamber guards tried their best to
subdue The Entity firing their weapons
at it but the bullets did nothing to
damage the creature's pale flesh or stop
its movements it ripped through the
steel Cube that contained it and knocked
the guards out of its way with one swipe
of its unnaturally long arms sending
them careening into a nearby wall
fortunately for them scp096 only knocked
them unconscious it didn't stop to harm
them further as it had a more important
goal in mind find the per person who had
seen its face and Destroy them as the
alarm blared signifying a high Threat
Level containment reach scp096 loes down
the hall toward Dr Bonita in SCP 914s
room Dr gears had not spotted Dr
Bonita's grave mistake and had no idea
what had triggered the alarm he was
hearing he stepped away from the
observation window turning his attention
to the crisis that was clearly happening
somewhere else in the facility meanwhile
Dr Bonita was panicking she saw saw her
life flash before her eyes the certainty
of impending doom that was coming for
her and coming fast all because of one
brief error in judgment what could she
do there was nowhere to hide no way she
could run away fast enough unless if she
managed to lure 096 into the intake
booth and start the machine while the
creature was inside maybe it would
transform into something less intent on
tearing her limb from limb it was a
risky move and one could jeopardize her
position at the foundation but she
couldn't very well keep her job if she
was dead so it seemed like it just might
be worth a shot a primal Roar of Agony
and fury interrupted her thoughts and
she knew that scp096 was moments away
from breaking down the door and getting
its hands on her she would have to move
fast with a screeching grind of metal on
metal scp096 wrenched the door off its
hinges and barreled into the room in its
search for the person person who had
seen its face it ran toward the
silhouette of Dr Bonita standing just at
the entrance to the intake Booth she
tucked and rolled out of the way just as
the monster entered the booth the door
automatically slid shut behind it and as
scp096 rattled the door and tried to
free itself she turned the knob to very
fine with every ounce of strength and
speed she had there was a ding of a
small Bell and the Machine word to life
as the objects inside were refined Dr
Bonita had no idea what would be waiting
for her in the output Booth but she
could only hope that her last ditch
effort had managed to save her life in
the fog of panic she briefly felt an
itch of scientific curiosity too what
would become of a being like scp096 in a
machine as strange and wonderful as SCP
914 what would the addition of the
statue do to it as the door to the
outtake Booth slid open Steam poured out
it appeared her questions would soon be
answered cautiously in spite of herself
Dr Bonita called out hello no one
answered but she heard the sound of
footsteps slow and careful as a figure
emerged from the Mist she covered her
mouth in shock her eyes wide dear God
she whispered in awe standing in front
of her with pale smooth skin and the
same imposing stature was the most
beautiful man she had ever seen wi dark
eyes Shone under thick sculpted eyebrows
under the eyes and aqualine nose full
pouty lips a strong sharp jawline his
head was topped with a tangle of
lustrious dark curls was the kind of
hair she had only seen flowing in the
Wind on the covers of the romance novels
she wanted desperately to buy but was
too embarrassed to be seen purchasing
his physique was well statuesque like
the build of the very Michelangelo
sculpture she had placed into the
machine just moments ago there was no
other way to say it he was handsome
despite still being a little lanky and 9
ft tall he peered at her curiously
towering over her in a way that had been
terrifying in his former shape but now
made her heart skip a beat in an
entirely different way hi was all she
could think to say was she blushing she
shook her head snapping herself out of
it she was a scientist damn it not some
giddy school girl passing notes in class
this was an incredible achievement
something she would need to study
thoroughly and she very much wanted to
study him thoroughly nope no time for
that she needed to write up a report to
inform her superiors to try her best not
to lose her job over this she had to
remain professional hi the man that had
once been or perhaps still was as CP 096
spoke oh you you can talk Dr Bonita
laughed in Surprise the man's brow
furrowed his new found ability to speak
was a surprise to him too it seemed yes
I can what happened to me yeah stumbling
over his words slightly getting used to
the feeling of them you ran into the
machine she gestured to scp-914 I'm not
exactly sure to be honest but you're
very different now he nodded I feel
different I feel calm he sighed the
relief playing on his face before a
shadow of sadness fell over him I don't
think I have to hurt anymore I I'm sorry
for what I did before Dr Bonita did not
know what to say how do you respond when
something you've been studying from afar
been horrified and fascinated by an
equal measure looks at you with a new
beautiful face and apologizes for all
the harm it caused this whole experience
was so surreal that she might think she
was dreaming if she didn't work at a
place that was one long waking dream or
nightmare depending on the day uh Dr
Bonita there's been a Containment Breach
are you all right Dr gears had returned
to the room taking in the sight of the
destruction left in 0 96's way I'm fine
she called to him and he followed her
voice into the room then stopped at the
sight of the transformed anomaly I don't
have time for whatever this is I trust
you'll handle it Dr gears took a long
sip of his coffee and taking Bonita's
shock silence as confirmation had a
leisurely stroll back to his office a
few moments later the guards responsible
for containing scp096 arrived on the
scene expecting to see Carnage and find
a docile scp096
crouched over a lifeless body but
instead they found the same truly
bizarre site that Dr gears had Shrugged
off and Dr Bonito was still doing her
best to process they entered the room
with their weapons drawn but quickly
lowered them scratching their heads in
confusion instead before ring their
superiors and asking for further
instructions responses from various
Foundation staff who caught a glimpse of
SCP 96's bold New Look included oh would
you look at that who's that guy he's
what and in the words of Dr Jack brigh
oh no he's
hot Dr brigh also proposed making the
new scp096 a Tik Tok account and YouTube
channel seeking modeling representation
for him or selling a novelty calendar
filled with pictures of 096 in various
costumes these would be in his words
quote excellent ways to increase revenue
for the foundation so really you're the
weird ones now for thinking my ideas are
weird Dr brgh was asked to leave as CP
096 alone and stopped trying to take his
headshot in the days that followed the
incident with SCP 914 the SCP Foundation
was at a loss about what to do with this
new seemingly harmless version of scp096
dozens of d-class were brought in to
look at his face and see if the entity
would still enter one of his rage States
after a few days of getting used to his
new form but he never did no screaming
no swallowing people whole nothing more
than a polite if somewhat shy greeting
and a courteous how are you doing today
the DCL classes were relieved but
confused about being pulled from their
cells just to stare at some random
handsome man Dr cleff suggested
dissecting scp096 to see what his new
body looked like on the inside this
request was denied several interviews
were conducted to evaluate scp096 is
mental and emotional state now that the
anomaly was capable of coherent speech
it was much simpler to evaluate the
Potential Threat Level he might pose
every researcher who spoke with him came
to the same conclusion gone was the
danger of the old scp096 he had not just
become beautiful in a classical
superficial sense but he had become
beautiful on the inside as well
interviewers reported a warm friendly
demeanor a talent for engaging in
conversation once he was made to feel
comfortable and a sincere interest in
the thoughts opinions and feelings of
those he spoke with there was only one
thing left to do to make sure that
scp096 had really change from something
deadly to something almost resembling an
ordinary person a photograph of scp096
his face of its original face was
removed from a Secure Vault by a d-class
then the d-class was sent into a room
with a scp096 and instructed to place
the photograph on the table SC scp096
looked down at what had once been his
face and his eyes filled with tears a
soft broken SOB left his lips and he
wrapped his arm arms arounded himself
hunching over as if in physical pain
outside the room guards prepared to
handle things if 096 began to attack
instead he wiped his tears took a deep
shuttering breath and looked at the
declass with a somber expression he
picked up the photograph on the table
and T it in half as he finally summoned
the strength to speak please get rid of
these that is not who I am anymore at Dr
Bonita's strong insistence backed up by
the conclusions of the research staff
who interviewed CP 096 A re-evaluation
of the entity's containment measure was
ordered it seemed cruel and unnecessary
waste of resources to keep 096 trapped
in a steel cube in its current form he
would be moved to a standard humanoid
containment cell and treated as well as
other safe class anomalies provided with
books films food and drink upon request
and of course other Comforts of course
the o5 council insisted on evaluating
The Entity before any of these changes
could be approved dressed in a specially
tailored suit provided by Dr Bonita
scp096 appeared before the council to
present his case I know that I might not
have the best record at the foundation
I've done a lot of damage over the years
though let's be honest you all aren't
exactly innocent either sorry that was
an attempt at a joke I'm still very new
to talking all I can say is please
consider giving me another chance to
make a real life here to make this place
my home thank you for your time what SC
scp096 didn't know is that the 05
Council was so flabbergasted by the
sight of his new face that they didn't
retain a single word he said they had
all given their official approval before
he even finished his short presentation
before long scp096 was moved out of his
steel Cube and into a new containment
chamber that resembled a mid-range
studio apartment complete with a bed a
kitchenet a television and a table and
chairs he was provided access to all
major streaming platforms as well as a
large stack of books to help him develop
his grasp of culture and language after
so very long being isolated from Human
Society though he wasn't exactly human
he was determined to act like it word
quickly spread around the foundation's
site and humans and anomalies alike
flocked to SCP 96's new home to visit
him and see the miraculous
transformation for themselves SCP 999
was the first to come and see the new
and improved 096 chirping excitedly as
it oozed into his room room he pet the
Slime gently his face breaking into a
warm Smile as its euphoric effect washed
over him the Slime became so excited at
meeting this new friend someone it had
known as a source of sadness and hurt
for so long that it tackled him to the
ground and tickled him for several
minutes 096 laughing uuly all the while
SCP 343 stopped by to give 096 his
Blessing and wish him well in this new
chapter of Life a few days later SCP 507
popped back into the s and wanted to see
the changes for himself he was
thoroughly impressed though privately
confessed to missing 0 96's more
monstrous form which reminded him of
some of his favorite Cryptids there was
one anomaly that was not thrilled with
the appearance of scp096
however SCP 056 was Furious upon hearing
about the new beautiful man that
everyone just couldn't shut up about it
demanded a chance to speak to scp096 and
to tell him that this place isn't big
enough for the both of us I'm the
fairest one of all you sniveling little
worm but the request was denied SCP 056
sulked about it for several weeks
meanwhile Dr Bonita was still intent on
getting to know scp096 better during
previous testing with SCP 978 the desire
camera a photo taken of scp096 revealed
that his greatest desire was to
disappear curious about the results
would be now Dr Bonita received
permission to take another picture of
SCP 096 she snapped the photo while 096
was sitting in a chair in his new
containment chamber looking directly at
the camera when the photo developed the
result was simple everything in the
picture was exactly the same with one
exception Dr Bonita was pictured sitting
next to 096 her hand clasped in his both
were smiling soft contented smiles when
she showed him the photograph he smiled
at her and shook his head it really is
an amazing camera she flushed doctor
before you go could I ask your name Dr
Bonita smiled and nodded it's Isabelle
what should I call you scp096 paused
thoughtfully for a moment he was giving
himself a name for the very first time
allowing himself an identity other than
a strange Hollow pale thing that existed
to cry and suffer and hurt finally he
answered her call me David what do you
do when the sun turns wrong when light
which once represented life joy and
warmth become comes a symbol of death
and destruction do you hide inside
shutter the windows keep out the light
by any means necessary do you Retreat
underground where the sun's Rays cannot
penetrate burrowing into the dark and
the cold do you simply give yourself to
it accepting that there is no escaping
something so vast so far reaching as
sunlight itself and allow yourself to be
lost in the end of all things we've
covered this possibility for SCP 001
when day breaks or SD locks proposal
it's difficult to know what any given
person might do in such harrowing
circumstances after all we have always
learned to love the light and fear the
darkness it turns our very understanding
of reality upside down to have that
Paradigm shifted the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death the
source of all life on Earth of all
warmth transforming in an instant from
the Sun as we know it to a Napoleon
class SCP that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze but
what about a being that has always
feared the light something that
prioritizes Solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when Daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one scp096
scp096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
Solitude would be in much Danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to Slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and proding that
might sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of Flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him as they never looked at his face all
he did was stay in his room and never go
outside the outside frightened him
terribly
though he was not concerned with the
deadly sunlight or the possibility of it
melting him as it had so many others he
was much more afraid that someone some
unlikely Survivor clinging to their
original life might look at him that
they might see his face that was simply
too distressing to risk he would much
rather stay alone in his old cell
weeping softly in the shadows one day
though we couldn't say how many days
after the end of things it had been then
he was weeping alone in his former cell
the days blurred together spent the same
way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
she was coming down the hall as much as
it could be called a hall anymore she
was coming towards his room to disrupt
his miserable peace he heard her steps
cross the threshold of his room and her
voice broke into a terrified scream no
doubt at the unexpected side of a pale
naked creature weeping in the corner of
what she expected to be an empty room
startled by the first loud sound he'd
heard in a long time in a world that had
mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized Screams had faded
into the soft slap of Flesh and slime on
the ground he turned around he shouldn't
ordinarily he wouldn't but he couldn't
stop himself there he saw a woman wide
eyes filled with tears face streaked
with dirt a small child next to her
holding her hand and clinging to her leg
just as he saw the woman she saw him she
saw his face anger boiled over inside of
him and he let out a scream wild primal
and filled with inhuman rage she could
not be looking at him seeing his face he
couldn't let her the woman ran with the
child in toe panicked by the wild Roar
and the sight of him standing upright
before her the anger faded as she left
his sight making her way down the hall
into the stairs but then he remembered
she had seen his face he could not let
her leave it was time to do something he
never thought he'd have to do again
again hunt his heightened senses picked
up the sound of muffled footsteps coming
up through the floor below him she was
downstairs just beneath the floor where
he was standing his instincts kicked in
and his body moved almost of its own
accord he lifted his long long arms
above his head and drove his hands down
into the floor it was weakened by the
ravages of the elements and time and
crumbled under his unnatural strength he
dug his claws into the plaster till
tearing it apart and cracking it into
pieces he pushed his claws in deeper and
deeper until he could feel them breaking
through the other side he pulled the
floor apart until the hole was wide
enough to fit through then dropped down
to the room below he spotted the woman's
back fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a Mad Dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
Terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no Escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she had crossed
from the Shadows into the harsh light of
the Sun the woman's eyes widened in Grim
understanding of her F he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious Rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the Sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening Splash her eyes were
next popping out of their sockets and
hanging loose and Limp on her cheeks and
dangling from siney strands she tried in
vain to stuff them back into place but
they squished in her hands like overripe
fruit she attempted to run into the
comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous Flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
Agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all sobbing and roaring in
frustration she was gone and he would
never get the satisfaction of ending her
The Infernal son had stolen her from him
now she was nothing but a wet shadow
like the rest of the humans had become
long ago he heard the sound of a soft
SOB behind him a tiny human voice he
turned looking for the source there was
the little girl he had almost forgotten
about her she was calling out for her
mother and crying and she was looking
right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake him but
instead there was nothing why wasn't he
angry she was looking at his face so why
then he realized
her eyes were on him but she did not see
him she was blind she approached the
creature her arms out stretched
following the sound of his crying she
touched his hand with her own tiny
fingers so small and fragile and asked
Mommy then he felt something he had
never felt before tenderness care a
desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm ever felt anything but sadness
anger or fear overcome with this
softness he wrapped his arms around the
child and hugged her close she hugged
him back tightly and the room went quiet
as they both stopped crying from that
day on they became a family of sorts
they lived together and he took care of
her she didn't know what he looked like
and had no idea he might be something to
fear to her he was safety he was home
for the first time in his long awful
life he felt like a Human Instead of a
monster he would scavenge food for her
bring her fresh water lay down stolen
blankets and pillows so she would have a
soft place to rest he even found her a
ratty worn teddy bear amongst the rubble
and gave it to her as a gift she
clutched it to her chest and thanked him
and for once his tears were those of joy
in this cursed World they had found
something like happiness in one another
he knew he would protect protect her no
matter what then one day everything
changed the creature and the little girl
were playing in the abandoned sight
making up little games together when he
took a break to look out at the window
and monitor their surroundings outside
the evil Red Sun waited when he turned
back the little girl was gone one of the
shadowy creatures once human was
imitating his voice to lure her away he
could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased
after her the only thing he had ever
loved and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light she screamed as one
of her arms began to melt in the light
and he knew what he had to do he grabbed
her and pulled her back inside using his
body to Shield her from the horrible
Rays as he wept over her his tears
stopped her body from melting any
further but his body continued to fall
apart it was too late for him he ran as
far as he could once he transformed he
did not want to end up hurting the girl
he ran until his legs melted away and he
could not run anymore he had reached the
shoreline and stared out at the ocean
unable to move anymore he screamed a
final time in agony in heartbreak in
mourning for the happiness he had
finally found and now would lose but at
least he knew as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone that the girl
would be saved
and then he was gone and the world was
quiet Dr Dan anxiously paced in his cell
it was the only way he'd been able to
occupy himself for the past 6 months
save for pouring through files and when
he was lucky being able to oversee
another failed termination attempt he
only stopped pacing when for a brief and
horrible moment he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing
in its big metal cube at this very
moment
that horrible creature that he'd thrown
away his life for a feudal shot at
killing perhaps the whole thing had been
a Fool's errand after all he was
formerly a researcher under the employ
of the SCP Foundation secure contain
protect they had truly sadistic beasts
like SCP 106 the nightmarish old man and
SCP 352 Baba Yaga in containment cells
and there was no plans to terminate
either of them they weren't the global
ult Coalition for 343's sake why did Dr
Dan even want to terminate scp096 in the
first place he tried to explain it to
them again and again but his pleas had
fallen on deaf ears in his mind the
impetus for destroying the shy guy was
terrifyingly clear it was a monster that
killed anyone or anything that looked at
its face even a photograph of it even a
tiny collection of pixels when its rage
state was in uced it seemed that nothing
would stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find it
Zen again once all of them were dead and
if a picture of scp096 was leaked onto
the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic it
prayed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seated in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in his many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of scp096 his face
would be leaked online perhaps a few
hundred people across the globe would
look in disperate enough locations that
it would be almost impossible for the
foundation to detect and save all of
them as scp096 went on its bloody
Rampage of course as the image
proliferated as images on the internet
often do the perview of 0 96's violence
would only grow people across the nation
would start to take notice and soon
after that across the world mysterious
creature causing Mass casualties would
be the headline on every news desk
because why would anybody want to talk
about anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with highdef cameras pictures would
be taken and posted more and more of it
would flood the internet too many
simultaneous moles for even the SCP
Foundation to whack the news would
spread spre panic and hysteria would
spread people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong we're refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp096 he was simply told to get back to
working on those goggles it was why he
needed to give those Nays a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain Mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civili Ian
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regrettable
but it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though Dr Dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate scp096 he was
discovering that he lacked another
important factor the capability they
tried incinerating it exposing it to
massive amounts of radiation exposing it
to an insane degree of kinetic trauma
the equivalent of being hit by an outof
control bullet train they tested every
kind of experimental offthe books
Weaponry that they had access to through
various research projects proton blasts
lasers high-intensity energy beams
nothing even when they fried off every
scrap of Flesh on the monster's body its
unbreakable skeleton still remained and
in what seemed like no time at all it'd
be back in Action its very existence
seemed to mock him a guard opened his
cell door staring disdainfully at the
disgraced researcher that same guard had
slammed his head against a wall a month
earlier one of his friends had
apparently been killed in the legendary
096 Containment Breach that set this
whole sorid thing in motion up and Adam
scumbag he said in a Gruff Surly voice
training a handgun on the doctor he knew
wouldn't fight back they need you in
test chamber six Dr Dan allowed himself
a small grin imperceptible to the guard
who clearly hated his guts they had
approved his 096 versus 682 cross test
marvelous how marvelous to all the
others it would seem like just one one
more entry in a long line of 682 cross
tests he thought it Darkly funny in his
eyes the foundation had no hope of ever
killing SCP 682 its defining quality was
being impossible to kill and it didn't
present nearly the threat to the entire
world that 096 posed their futile
attempts to murder the lizard were
little more than a money sync to justify
the site's exorbitant funding but
perhaps he could turn this to his
benefit maybe SCP 682 would hold the
secret to actually killing off his
Nemesis within 30 hours Dr Dan had his
disappointing answer both anomalies had
undeniably done a real number on each
other and Dr Dan did take a kind of sick
Amusement in the mental trauma that SCP
682 had induced in
096 but ultimately it was all for
nothing 682 had skin 096 alive and
melted off its flesh with acid but once
again that indestructible skeleton stood
firm this had been the 27th termination
attempt since the incident the 27th
failed termination attempt Dr Dan
mentally corrected himself 0 96's
skeleton kept defeating them even their
most Ardent attempts to penetrate the
bones and destroy the creature within
had failed during a previous attempt
they tried to access the brain by
putting a diamond hard drill into its
eye sockets of course it was the the
drill that actually broke much to Dr
Dan's seemingly tireless frustration
needless to say in the debriefing
interview with Dr Carver a researcher
who once would have considered him a
colleague he wasn't in High Spirits if
he managed to kill this thing then he
would always be the hero who made a
terrible sacrifice in order to save many
more lives if he didn't kill 096 he was
little more than the monster who
murdered all those innocent people for
nothing though you'd never hear him say
it out loud if it wasn't for that
damnable indestructible skeleton this
monster would be long dead already if
only there was some way to break the
creature's bones that's when it hit him
SCP 173 the sculpture a sight 19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body body
count since it was first interred at
site 19 in
1993 one broken neck at a time and it's
one of the few creatures out there that
even the hardto destroy reptile himself
is utterly terrified of perhaps a
monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the shy guys's
vertebrae once his proposal was greenlit
for initial testing Dr Dan arranged for
the shy guy with a bag over his head of
course to be brought brought into a
testing chamber with the ever stoic SCP
173 when all the researchers and guards
were safely outside all it took was a
single blink to make all of Dr Dan's
darkest dreams come true in the Nan
seconds his eyes were closed he heard
the most beautiful sounds in the world a
loud fleshy Crunch and a pained howl
from
096 he opened his eyes to an equally
wondrous sight 096 doubled over at an
unnatural angle angle its spine snapped
between the fourth and fifth vertebrae
spinal fluid leaking down the creature's
flank that freaky little sculpture had
done it it had actually damaged the
Integrity of the shyy skeleton it was at
that moment that dror Dan knew he could
kill this thing admittedly there was a
Containment Breach shortly after that
when the bag slipped off of 0 96's head
and it charged through the nearby steel
wall killing multiple people before
being subdued and recontained but when
it comes to projects involving Dr Dan a
mere handful of innocent people being
killed sits comfortably within the
acceptable margin of error a day later
Dr Dan was standing before a crowded
boardroom with agents researchers and
even a few members of the 05 Council in
attendance he explained his findings to
them and the fact that even more
importantly they may have a way to bring
The Wretched existence of 096 to an
absolute halt his plans were approved
not long after he was putting them into
motion Dr Dan was surrounded by
researchers and heavily armed guards as
173 was escorted into the test chamber
with a forklift 096 was there still
bagged off to the side was a giant tub
of hydrofluoric acid connected to a hose
and injector attachment if this didn't
work nothing would everyone stood back
in a safe Zone as 173 was released to do
its thing crunch just like the previous
time 0 96's spine had been successfully
snapped spinal fluid dribbled down its
skin everyone had rushed into the
chamber one group kept 173 isolated with
their stairs the other headed by Dr Dan
prepared the acid injector and shoved it
into the breach in 0 96's spine as the
acid was pumped by the gallon into 0
96's Bones the creature let out the most
horrifying whale it kicked and bucked as
more acid was pumped in melting those
indestructible Bones from within the
creature even began to vomit acid as it
panicked melting the bag off of its own
head some panicked and averted their
gaze Dr Dan didn't he stared directly at
the creature's face for the first time
as it melted in front of him with
nothing short of Pur relation had he won
had he actually won the creature let out
a gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monster's melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and shrieked they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a madman even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd finally won
that's right it's time once again to
activate the fame onomaton 6000 our
patented machine that definitely wasn't
developed in affiliation with Dr Wonder
tainment we swear after recalibrating
rebooting and hitting restart our
Infamous special ized supercomputer is
ready to bring you all manner of
improbable scenarios we'll simulate
encounters between the SCP foundation's
various anomalies and any other
character from any other Universe you
could possibly imagine here's a question
for you what do you think would happen
if scp096 the notorious shy guy ran a
foul of someone he couldn't just kill
for daring to look at it what if the
scourge of the underworld battler of
demons and the Devil Himself set his
sight on scp096 while we're about to hit
the button and discover the outcome of
scp096 versus the dreaded Dooms Slayer
so you've heard the old philosophical
debate about a tree falling down in the
woods and whether or not nobody being
around to hear it brings into question
if it actually happened at all right
well let's reframe that one a little if
an interdimensional rip in the very
fabric of the time space continuum opens
up in an SCP Foundation secure facility
and nobody is around to witness it does
a 6' tall 360 lb hulking killing machine
still emerge to slaughter everything in
his path it turns out yes yes he
definitely does horrified screams and
the loud bang of shotgun blasts rang out
through the hallway as Foundation
researchers ran for their lives the Doom
Marine had just been unceremoniously
dropped out of a portal into a strange
and unfamiliar environment mere minutes
earlier he had been awake wakened inside
a sarcophagus within a facility on Mars
in the year
2148 unfortunately Doom guy hadn't had
the best start to his day given that the
base he'd woken up in was being overrun
by the forces of Hell itself thanks to a
rogue scientist opening up portals to
the underworld and allowing all manner
of demonic Abominations to come pouring
through so naturally when another portal
brought the armor-clad Demon Slayer to a
site run by the SCP Foundation the
intensity of battle had led to the
doomslayer believing that the
unsuspecting staff were actually all
demons in Disguise and to him the only
good Demon is one he got to send back to
hell in the most brutal fashion
imaginable he wasn't going to stop until
he torn through wave after wave a
foundation Personnel thinking perhaps if
he killed enough he'd be returned to his
previous local for more demon killing as
the foundation dispatched its security
forces and mobile task force to take
down the Unstoppable force of Carnage
stucked out in head to toe green armor
it seemed nothing they could throw at
the Doom Marine was enough to take him
down a hail of bullets rained down on
him from the mtfs weapons ricocheting
ineffectually off his protective plating
as he continued his assault remaining
tireless thanks to his immense physical
conditioning the SCP Foundation tried
and failed to contain Doom Guai they
assumed him to either be a new
undocumented anomaly or a violent and
unhinged Maniac from the church of the
broken God given his armor resembling
cybernetic augmentations and machine
parts grafted to his body along with his
arsenal of advanced Weaponry but there
were no enhancements no augmentations
made to the Dooms Slayer he may have
once been mortal but centuries of
killing demons had allowed him to
transcend ordinary human physiology he
did not Tire never lost strength never
needed to eat or drink in and was near
enough Immortal yet among all the chaos
that was unfurling a solitary researcher
had just managed to slip out of the Doom
slayer's reach he ran as fast and far as
he was physically able the mobile task
force troops were getting eviscerated
and The Slayer could easily tear through
the whole Foundation then fleeing for
his life the researcher had an idea
either a stroke of Genius or total
idiocy and a risky move either way he
would send an anomaly on the Doom Slayer
he turned to the nearest containment
cell a windowless room with a heavy
locked door hurly inputting his security
clearance code the researcher heaved the
door open and covered his eyes with his
arm it wouldn't have been his first
choice of SCP to send into battle SCP
96's cell was the closest lumbering out
of its containment chamber on its
misshapen elongated legs scp096 scanned
the area alarms were glaring it was loud
and frightening to the timid aliit
terrifying creature it reached up to
cover its ears in bewilderment not that
the researcher who had freed it could
see what it was doing for one his eyes
were still covered and for another he
was already dead thanks to the Dooms
Slayer barging shoulder first through a
nearby wall and raining debris onto the
nearby researcher beneath the visor of
his helmet the Marine breathed heavily
panting but not tiring as he looked at
the pale skinny creature in the Cor door
before him it was clutching the sides of
its head its huge jaw hung open as far
as the Slayer knew he was making
progress his attack was working he'd
killed enough of these demonic imposters
that they were starting to reveal their
true forms although in all his years of
Bloodshed and being a scourged to the
Denison of hell he hadn't quite ever
seen a demon that looked like the shy
guy not that it mattered to Doom guy
before long it'd be dead like all the
rest the Towering stick thin creature
turned to face the armor adorned Warrior
and shrieked immediately overcome with
anguish having a full-blown breakdown as
it often did whenever someone looked at
it as the demon killer stomped down the
corridor towards it the doomblade a long
Sleek Raaz or sharp edge extended from
the slayer's gaet where it was mounted
on his wrist he reached down and yanked
the rip cord on his chainsaw too he was
long overdue for a glory kill but before
he could strike at scp096 the shy guy
move moved with impossible speed faster
than even the Doom Marine himself it
zipped behind the encroaching Marine
moving quicker than he could perceive 1
second scp096 was crying and wailing in
front of him then not even a full second
later the creature was towering over
Doom guy from behind scp096 gripped the
Doom blade and snapped it with ease like
breaking a twig before reaching its
other long arm down and pulling the
chainsaw from Doom guy's hand the
motorized blade was still running as it
clattered to the ground cutting a hole
through the floor and falling down into
the lower level of the facility enraged
as he very often was the Dooms Slayer
reached both arms back behind his head
and gripped the elongated torso of
scp096 the virtually Immortal killing
machine hurled the creature over his
head with ease thanks of course to his
immense strength Doom guy could lift
objects far heavier than most ordinary
humans and carry heavy weapons without
tiring he had even grappled hand to hand
with demons throwing the shy guy down
the corridor like hurling a basketball
was no trouble for the space fairing
slaughterer of Satan spawn screaming and
Howling in pain as CP 096 crashed to the
ground at the far end of the corridor
tumbling over itself thanks to its long
limbs before landing in a confused Heap
as the shy guy reoriented itself
struggling back onto its feet and
standing up at its full height it was
instantly knocked back down as the force
of something Struck it barring down on
scp096 the Doom machine charged his
signature double barreled saw off
shotgun drawn it was hardly leaving a
scratch on scp096 his pale skin despite
the moderate amount of damage the weapon
was capable of two shots would ring out
reeling the creature but not harming it
then by the time scp096 managed to
recover from the blast the Slayer had
finished reloading in time to open fire
yet again even as the Doom Slayer race
nearer closing the distance between him
and what he thought to be another demon
for him to kill the shotgun seemed to
have little effect against the shy guy
at close range stowing the weapon Doom
guy put all of his focus and energy into
his charge heavy boots stomping against
the ground as he raced towards the shy
guy still stunned by the latest shotgun
blast before the creature could steady
itself this time it was struck by
another force a heavy object barreling
towards it the Dooms Slayer shoulder
barged SCP 96 sending the pair of them
crashing through the nearest wall they
burst into a neighboring room with a
doom Slayer keeping a single armed grip
around the shy guy while repeatedly
delivering vicious punches to its gut
with his other hand not once relenting
as scp096 screeched in pain clawing at
the Slayer but unable to tear through
his impenetrable armor as they crashed
through yet another wall scp096 did
something it rarely ever did in fact
Maybe something it had never ever done
before it ran away from someone that had
looked at it while the creature was
deeply insecure and so self-conscious
that it would kill anyone who saw so
much as a photograph of it it didn't
often feel afraid but the Dooms Slayer
this musclebound killing machine that
had brutally butchered actual demons was
so imposing so threatening and so
effective at dispensing painful
punishment that he scared the fight out
of scp096
sobbing with Terror the creature zipped
away using its anomalous speed trying
desperately to put as much distance
between it and the Doom Marine as it
possibly could but therein lay the
problem no sooner had scp096 gotten away
from the scourge of hell then the
creature immediately felt the familiar
pull whether it was an inescapable
compulsion to kill everyone who looked
at it or the fact of the Shy Guy's
biology It could only distance itself
from the Slayer for a few seconds before
it re appeared next to him from the
doomu perspective it seemed like the
creature was intentionally disappearing
and reappearing using its teleportation
like speed to evade a volley of his
attacks scp096 came at him again stuck
in a loop of trying to attack the
doomslayer for looking at it to
immediately regretting that course of
action and fleeing in fear of its
hulking heavy weapon toading Target Doom
guy Drew every weapon he had in his
Arsenal launching a barrage of high
explosive ordinance from from his rocket
launcher to try and kill scp096 the
resulting damage practically reduced an
entire wing of the foundation sight to
Rubble but still couldn't kill the
slayer's opponent meanwhile in the
moments that the shy guy temporarily
forgot his own fear for the Doom guy it
managed to rush towards him swiping the
Marine's various technologically
advanced armaments out of his hands
before instantly remembering why he was
so scared of the green armored force of
Destruction and dashing away Doom guys
supply of weapons had all but depleted
neither he nor scp096 were getting tired
out by their constant back and forth
they were locked in a stalemate until
the shy guy tried to get back to its
cell zipping away once again it cowed in
the corner reaching for an old wornout
paper bag that it slipped over its head
it sat down trembling rocking back and
forth in a fetal position the shy guy
was terrified an overwhelming
debilitating fear gripped it fear that
became pure dread as the sound of heavy
boots began to stomp closer and closer
kicking the steel door off its hinges
the Dooms Slayer walked into scp096 cell
carrying something huge in his hands it
was one of the most devastating weapons
Doom guy had at his disposal capable of
unleashing Untold destruction The BFG
9000 without remorse not caring that the
creature seemed to have retreated and
was caring away from him the Slayer
raised the powerful weapon and fired an
enormous ball of green energy the blast
engulfed the entire room tendrils
snaking out from the energy projectile
causing additional damage to the
surrounding area until there was nothing
left of scp096
it happened in
1981 in a small rural Village in West
Germany s 9 years old ran across the
bitter snow tears freezing to his cheeks
it was was Christmas Day and not long
ago he'd been so happy he was
celebrating with his family his mother
his father and his young sister the
centers of his Universe when that
monster had attacked and destroyed
everything he'd ever known the white
Terror the destroyer of Christmas cheer
the uan as CP
4666 though of course young SEF fleed
had no idea in hindsight se's parents
had been noticing strange things in the
leadup to Christmas Day unfamiliar bumps
and knocks strange smells coming from
the attic the occasional tall dark
silhouette on the horizon outside their
isolated old farmhouse but in all the
hustle and bustle of the Season nobody
really paid the proper attention to all
the signs of an incoming hoist KN event
every Eerie feeling was just written off
as stress or overactive imag in inations
none of the G family knew about the true
danger they were facing until they woke
up to see the uan standing over them
sharpening a rusty blade and staring at
them with hungry sadistic eyes Merry
Christmas the creature rasped and
chuckled cleed was lucky to escape alive
but of course he would never see his
family again he'd be picked up a day or
so later traumatized catatonic and
almost frozen to death when he was
finally able to speak again he spoke of
a monster having killed his family when
the police investigated his home and
found the remains they deemed it to be
the work of an all to human serial
killer and poor sik fedge was entered
into the Foster system years of work
with psychiatric professionals tried to
convince young seed that the monster he
claimed to see the unnaturally tall
naral bony freak with those shimmering
black eyes was merely a product of his
trauma but but he knew the truth he
always knew what he encountered that day
the thing that took his family was
nothing less than a true monster and at
9 years old Sig fed made a vow he would
one day kill the monster no matter what
it took when sfid was finally adopted
and returned to school he did everything
he could to apply himself academically
he had no interest in friends or
romantic relationships even as he grew
into his teenage years
the only thing that Drew his interest in
addition to the Perfection of his
academic life was his own private
Research into the supernal he became an
expert in all things occultic and
anomalous sightings of ghosts Phantoms
aliens and monsters he wanted to know it
all no needed to know it all he would
arm himself with knowledge wanting to
know everything he could in advance of
the confrontation that would be his
final Destiny he also began obsessively
researching attacks similar to the ones
that killed his family and found an
eerie pattern seemingly to unfold all
over the Northern Hemisphere during the
12 Days of Christmas entire families
would be found dead in their homes
mutilated horrifically often with
children having gone completely missing
they happened far enough apart in terms
of time and space that no connection was
drawn between the events all just random
attacks according to the police and
media weren't the connections obvious he
didn't
understand it it was almost like there
was some kind of sweeping cover up
obscuring the true culprit behind all
these killings the same Beast that
destroyed his life as s freed now known
to most as Dr G ascended through his
time at University he became one of
Germany's foremost Scholars on the
occult with several published papers and
books that Drew fascination of fellow
experts and laymen alike but most
importantly of all seek Freed's work got
the attention of the SCP found
Foundation they reached out to the
ambitious rising star of the Paranormal
world and offered him a research
position Dr G was elated and said that
he would happily take the role if they
answered one question for him did they
know anything about a horrific humanoid
monster that attacked families across
the Northern Hemisphere around Christmas
time this was the moment when Dr SE guys
after Decades of searching finally came
to know about SCP 46 66 he had access to
all of the SCP foundation's information
on the monster putting him several steps
closer to what had always been his
ultimate goal killing that godforsaken
thing but this would be easier said than
done after all if the uan was easy to
track the foundation would have captured
and contained him long before now his
attacks could occur anywhere across the
Northern Hemisphere making catching him
the world's largest game of Whac-A-Mole
but this was a game that Dr gu had more
than enough patience to play over The
Following years Dr gu worked as hard as
humanly possible not just at the case of
SCP
4666 but at every piece of work the
foundation had to offer him much like
his ruin childhood guys made no effort
to interact no effort to form social
connections he just worked and worked
and worked and worked with single-minded
passion soon developing a reputation as
one of the most most hardworking and
dependable figures in the SCP
foundation's European division it was
this kind of work ethic that soon saw
him promoted to senior researcher and
then a site director he had more control
over information resources and Manpower
than ever before it was almost time he
could sense it delegating other tasks to
his subordinates Dr gu began to work on
his Masterpiece an advanced algorithm
connecting police social social media
and surveillance databases across the
Northern Hemisphere you see while Dr G
had never faltered in his quest neither
had the uul man every year more families
disappeared or were horrifically
murdered and every death weighed on guys
he saw them as a personal failing of his
of his inability to fulfill his Destiny
but the uul man was a creature of habit
and it would be that very adherence to
Habit that guys used to destroy it using
the algorithm he created
they would perfectly track and
triangulate the home most likely to be
the subject of a dreaded event with
greater accuracy and precision than ever
before the year was 2022 Dr G was
convinced that this time he would be the
one to claim victory and Vengeance there
was one thing he didn't tell his
foundation compatriots though as he put
the pieces in place for the final
showdown he had no intention of
containing the U man this time he would
destroy destroy it using his Newfound
influence as a well-respected site
director he requested the transfer of a
few high-profile anomalies as well as
the services of a crack mobile task
force death squad it was time the U man
watched the house from a distance he'd
been observing for days watching the
nice happy family within what pleasure
it would bring him to destroy them and
take what's left to his workshop for
further fun tonight would be the night
that he claimed them they were all
blissfully unaware and lived in an
isolated rural area where nobody but him
would hear all the wonderful screaming
the second the lights went out inside
the house he would strike and bring
about some Christmas fear when the last
window went dark the uan drew a long
Rusty blade out of his bag of tricks and
approached the house he crept in through
one of the windows locks had never been
a problem for him this whole process had
played out hundreds of times he barely
even needed to think about it now he
crept in past the presents around the
Christmas tree found the stairs and
began to climb he'd find them in their
beds one by one and take his time
savoring the pain savoring the fear he
went into the youngest one's bedroom
first his lips pulled back into a manic
grin there was the little boy tucked in
under his quilt like a present waiting
to be unwrapped he grabbed the sheet
with his long gnarled fingers and pulled
it back only only to see a plastic dummy
underneath with a stun grenade fixed to
its chest before the uan could even
react the stun grenade exploded into his
face blinding him with a sudden white
light and ringing in his ancient ears
the next thing he heard was a rugged
military voice yelling Squad Alpha move
in seconds later the upstairs Landing
was filled with mobile task force
operatives with assault rifles they
aimed an open fire into the uan
peppering him with painful bullets he
wasn't used to his victim's fighting
back like this truthfully it even caught
him off guard but sadly for those Brave
task force operatives it would not be
enough to kill him the uan gripped his
Rusty knife and lunched at Squad Alpha
moments later they were all dead and the
Furious uan was trudging back down the
stairs there had been no satisfaction in
this Slaughter how had they caught him
like this perhaps he'd go eat some of
his servants in his Workshop to make
himself feel better as he walked back
across the living room past the
Christmas tree past all the presents the
television flickered into life staring
at him from the screen was the grinning
face of doct siked G Now 50 years old
and the most insane part was that the U
man somehow recognized him the one who
got away 41 years prior hello old friend
you're looking a little glum Sig freed
said on the screen I take it that you
did not enjoy the surprise party I just
threw for you don't don't worry the
night isn't over yet after all you
haven't even opened your presents
without the presents under the tree
which were actually packed with C4
plastic explosives detonated leveling
the entire house with the uan still
inside the explosion could be heard for
Miles as a great pillar of smoke rose up
into the air several hundred meters away
Dr sid3 guys waited and watched flanked
by Foundation agents and more mobile
task force soldiers taking in the
Majesty of the explosion Dr gu remained
steeli and watched The Blaze somehow he
knew that even that would not be enough
to end the monster permanently he nodded
to the lieutenant he'd brought with him
Squad out Squad Bravo time to engage the
man barked in response the remaining
agents and MTF operatives armed with
assault rifles and submachine guns
descended on the burning wreckage of the
house moments later a tall dark figure
the U man injured but alive craw crawled
out of the blaze immediately the team
opened fire giving the monster
everything they had but once again
everything was not enough the creature
pulled out two long Rusty knives and
leaped Into The Fray making short work
of the foundation brass soon enough it
stood alone on bloodstained snow until
it caught another bullet in the head Dr
seed guys was standing there The Last
One Alive to face the uan leveling a
revolver the uan scalled guys held his
Ste gaze we meet again at long last Sig
freed said you killed my family you've
killed so many others tonight it is your
turn you man this is your WN guys opened
fire as the uan charged towards him
taking each shot in stride even as the
uan closed the distance guys didn't
Flinch his resolve was Steely it made
the man feel confused and Furious that
he didn't detect an ounce of fear in
this man even when he drove a knife into
the psite director's stomach s freed
dropped to his knees and collapsed as
the uan ripped the knife back out his
gun clattered to the ground it had been
a mortal blow and still he seemed
unfazed why aren't you afraid the U man
growled Sig freed Splat blood and said
you took my family 41 years ago
everything since then has just been
killing time until I got to see them
again where you're going all you'll ever
see are flames and dorment the Yu man
Furious stabbed sigf freed again this
time through the heart the doctor was
dying his life's work having seemingly
amounted to nothing but with the last of
his strength he reached into his coat
and pulled out something a little gift
he'd requested from one Dr Alto cleff
before putting his plan into action Dr
seeked guys lifted a photo of scp096
right in front of the U Man's eyes Merry
Christmas he said with his last breath
the uan was confused a photograph was
that it was that really this foolish
little boy's trump card after all this
time what a waste then without a
moment's warning scp096 barreled into
the U man sending them both rolling
across the snow one of Sig Freed's
preparations was to have scp096 is
containment Cube temporarily relocated
to only a mile away from the Ambush site
to avoid collateral damage if everything
else failed then scp096 would be their
Hail marry pass their finishing move and
it worked marvelously as strong and evil
as the uan was he'd been weakened by the
knight's battle and the shy guy was an
order of magnitude more powerful than
his sadistic foe the uan screamed in
horror as SCP 096 set upon him with
claws and teeth after hundreds of years
inflicting it on others the uan had died
in Terror and Dr sepl guys had died with
a smile on his face he's waiting for you
in the dark he sits cross-legged still
as a Placid Lake and patient as a
Praying monk 6 feet deep in meditation
he's been like this for so long his body
oil slicked with deadly black grease
skin ancient and Haggard eyes black and
flat with the kind of calm you would
only find in crawling insects and great
white sharks his lipless mouth is
stretched across his Jawbone in an ugly
black Rus he may be an old man but trust
us he's got plenty of New Tricks he'd
love to show you he sat in the lonliest
place in the world the deep dark bowels
of an SCP found Foundation containment
site surrounded by a complex Confluence
of containment measures different shapes
running liquids Bright Lights the kind
of Steel so thick a nuclear weapon would
only leave it scuffed all the things
that had a tendency to confuse him
because that's all they ever did the old
man laughed to himself very quietly all
the people out there are so scared of
him because of one immutable fact he
isn't trapped here he's just resting by
virtue of his unique anomalous abilities
to pass through solids at will and
resist any form of physical damage they
canull out there is no way to really
contain him like all the others all the
SCP Foundation could hope to do was make
leaving inconvenient enough for him to
make his little adventures on the
outside less appealing than just sitting
around doing nothing after all he had
all the time in the world when you
always have a later there's a lot less
pressure to do anything now but like all
thinking creatures and Please be aware
that
scp-106 The Wretched terrifying old man
is very much a thinking creature he was
subject to occasional boredom and when
most people are bored they might play a
video game watch a few YouTube videos or
rewatch It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia for the fifth time but for
the old man killing boredom involved
well killing people but not just killing
people of course truth be told for him
killing was really the least
entertaining part of the whole Affair
the screams the begging the desperate
pleas warm tears on shaking cheeks
convulsions of pain cold sweats fear so
intense it gives way to gibbering
Madness the dull Sheen of dead hope in
their eyes when they realize that their
Doom is inevitable and that he their
captor their torturer would decide the
exact moment they slipped into the void
oh that that was what he lived for if
you could call what the old man did
living He cracked his neck and licked
his teeth was he salivating all those
thoughts about pain seemed to have got
him worked up he could feel the distant
thumping of his heart old black blood
pumping through the dusty corridors of
his vascular system synapses booming and
sparking with excitement at the thought
of Plumbing new depths of human misery
like a scholar of suffering a pioneer of
pain all those silly Foundation drones
with the audacity to think they're in
control he'd teach them to scream again
meanwhile in the room for the old man's
containment chamber all hell was
breaking loose monitors on the monster
vitals were all spiking hard and brain
activity peaked just as they always did
before the old man decided to get active
cameras and in his containment chamber
showed him Rising steadily to his feet
cracking his joints limbering up his
body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate
pooling around his feet and unleashing
squalls of noxious fumes as it melted
into the floor years of foundation
testing and they still couldn't find any
material that could withstand that vile
black sloth as the old man began
strolling towards the wall a containment
specialist in the control room grabbed a
nearby phone and sounded the alarm for
the Containment Breach they needed a
mobile task force and every guard on
site mobilized to tackle 106 before he
got into the facility proper and started
causing Havoc they couldn't risk it
escaping either the infamous incident
when the old man escaped for a Halloween
Massacre still haunted the nightmares of
many a staff member he had to be stopped
now a small fighting force was quickly
armed and assembled along with armor and
several high-intensity portable lights
to hopefully slow the monster down in
time for them to grab a d-class and set
up the femur Breaker by the time they
all reached the hallway they intended to
use as a choke point for the escape the
old man was already halfway through the
outer layer of Defense phasing through
the wall with that same terrible manic
grin he always had when he was about to
inflict terrible violence for the sheer
fun of it the guards and task force
members trained their lights and weapons
on him all of them had seen terrible
things on the JW the kind of of things
that would saddle almost anyone with a
lifetime of trauma but almost nothing
compared to the horror of direct
engagement during a 106 Containment
Breach that terrible old coffin Dodger
was hell on two legs when they
discovered to their horror that the
lights didn't seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated they fell
back on Plan B that b standing for blast
the living hell out of him with
everything they had the Personnel opened
fire pumping round after round into his
dark form while each gave a loud meaty
splatter the old man didn't even Flinch
when he was close enough all those
months of lethargy gave way to sudden
deadly speed in many ways the old man
was like a crocodile a Fierce and
intelligent Ambush Predator who
conserved his energy wisely he could
seem so deceptively languid that you
could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless but when you got
within Arm's Reach the sudden quickness
and ferocity would take you off guard
and by then it's already too late within
30 seconds the old man was the only left
alive in that hallway all the guards and
task force operatives sent to slow him
down lay dead dripping with his black
mucus there was silence save for The
Quiet fizzing of the mucus eating into
their clothes and skin the old man side
how boring he'd killed so many people
now it all started to seem a little
Sam me how many screams could you hear
before they all just blended into a
single shrill wine you can get sick of
even your favorite meal if you eat it
too often but that didn't matter the old
man had a different order of business
today he happened to be inside an SCP
Foundation containment facility filled
with so many fascinating specimens of
non-human entities that the one they
called
scp-106 simply couldn't wait to torture
he'd only met a small portion of the
ones they had contained here but given
what a fascinating experience his past
attack on his fellow anomalies was he
couldn't wait to meet some more
meanwhile the sight's top brass did all
they could to try to mobilize a second
response to the Rogue senior citizen
from Hell currently strolling through
their high security containment facility
could they get in contact with other
mobile task forces deployed in the area
maybe they could get hammer down or
samsara in on this mess before anything
got really out of hand the old old man
seemed more intent on something this
time they suspected even the femur
breaker might not work in luring him
back until he claimed whatever he deemed
to be his prize maybe they should
contact the 05 Council security guards
were tracking 106's progress through the
facility via their vast networks of
security cameras they warned any
research Administration and janitorial
staff to clear out of his path unless
they felt like being tortured to death
he hadn't dragged anyone into his pocket
Dimension yet so whoever that privilege
was reserved for would probably be
getting a particular sticky experience
they could only speculate as to the
silent beasts intentions one guard
noticed something when cross referencing
106's movements with a map of the
facility they were able to triangulate
where he was heading straight for the
containment chamber of scp096 the
guard's lips curled into a slight smile
thinking if one of you freaks can
actually kill the other Maybe something
positive Will Come Out of This Disaster
the old man was having a stroll down
memory lane the time prior when he broke
out of his cell and decided to hassle
his fellow inmates was certainly
eventful he wound up in the company of
some kenris reptile and a Korean foxw
woman an unlikely pair if ever there was
one after finding himself in a room with
them he decided they should have a
little more privacy and dragged them
back into his pocket dimension for
further fun of course with two at once
his attention had been a little split
they spent as much time tussling with
each other as resisting his attempts to
torment them they definitely put him
through his Paces that day and he gave
far better than he got after so many
hours of brutal mutilation there was
barely any of the lizard left despite
its frustrating insistence on quickly
healing from so many of its wounds still
it was good exercise even if the results
had been a little less than satisfying
if he could get another an alone though
he'd be able to take his time and really
Savor the pain he caused oh that sounded
Heavenly soon he came upon an incredibly
strange containment chamber that quickly
caught his eye it looked like a huge
metal cube with no way in or out not
even a seam whatever was trapped in
there the old man thought it must be
something that even the fools at the SCP
Foundation really truly wanted nothing
to do with but even more so than the
strange sight it was the sound that Drew
the old man in tempting him like a siren
song it was weeping a soft sobbing Keen
that betrayed a bottomless well of
misery whatever was making that crying
sound had known true despair or whatever
passes for True despair before you've
had a close encounter with the old man
in his pocket Dimension the old man
grinned and thought Oh Sunny I'll give
you something to really cry about he
stepped forward and phased his way into
the metal cube the creature was in the
corner in contrast to that stupid lizard
this monster was pleasingly humanoid
with presumably all the familiar pain
points Splendid the only real difference
was color and proportion it was far
longer and gangli than the average human
with grayish skin and no hair anywhere
on its body still it was something the
old man could work with the creature
didn't even seem to register his
presence he just sat crumpled in the
corner weeping still grinning his
lunatic grin The Old Man approached and
rested a moist hand on the creature's
shoulder its pale skin began to fizzle
from the intruder's corrosive touch a
pool of vile sludge began spreading out
beneath his feet until the creature was
encompassed too little by little they
sank into the old man's favorite place
out of the world the pocket Dimension
his own personal Eternal infinite
dungeon where the only laws are pain and
Terror for all but the old man himself
little did he know this time the scores
may be a little more even on that front
they both stood in that terrifying
Labyrinth of hallways and Chambers where
the old man had made countless lives
infinitely worse than any terrible
afterlife that could follow them and
still this creature didn't seem to
change its reaction he was almost
irritated by it and what's more this
whole time the creature hadn't even turn
to look at him he'd have to fix that too
the old man with his shocking strength
gripped the monster's shoulder and
whipped him around staring into his face
bearing his black eyes and manic smile
but he couldn't help find what looked
back at him
disconcerting its eyes were blank and
white its face stretched and warped into
a permanent Grimace like Munch's old
painting The Scream and the second the
old man laid eyes on it that's exactly
what what it did its gaping mouth let
out the most terrible whale the old man
had ever heard in all his years of
torturing it was a scream of un Noble
sadness and fear but somehow the old man
sensed that this creature didn't fear
Him it feared itself feared what it was
about to do what the hell had he dragged
down here with him without warning the
terrible whales soon gave way to sudden
and ferocious aggression just like the
old man had dealt out to a group of
foundation guards and mobile task Force
agents earlier that same night it was
only out of a mix of pure luck and his
own finely tuned animal Instinct that
the old man was able to dodge the first
strike from the creature's long LIF for
liim he couldn't believe it they were in
his special place and this victim of his
had the audacity to fight back well he'd
soon put this monster in its place as
the monster continued roaring and
swiping for him the Old Man simply
walked backwards into a nearby wall and
disappearing into into a black stain of
course the monster better known to the
foundation as scp096 or the shy guy
simply crash through the wall to give
Chase but on the other side just another
wall he disappeared how typically when
something sees the face of the shy guy
he immediately has a kind of intuitive
connection to them he can sense their
presence it's burned into his mind a
homing Beacon an Unstoppable imperative
he knows exactly where they are and how
to get them but nothing about this
situation was typical the shy guy felt
all the murderous rage he normally did
but the rest was just static where was
the life he needed to abolish hiding
suddenly the old man emerged behind him
and forced his hand into the Shy Guy's
back his fist melted straight through
flesh and skin causing the creature to
let out another terrible whale but as
could be expected they didn't leave a
scratch on the Shy Guy's indestructible
skeleton the shy guy pulled the 180 and
swung for the old man again but he was
already gone here in the pocket
Dimension the old man had the ultimate
home turf Advantage here space and time
were his play things in the infinite
twisting Labyrinthian walls of the
pocket Dimension the old man wasn't just
the devil he was God too but it would
take far more than some cheap tricks and
bodily harm to dissuade the shy guy from
his sole purpose in life he began
running through the old man's personal
maze like a crazed labat tearing through
wall after wall for forever searching
for the monster that trapped it here it
would see the smiling face of that
rotten old man every so often the flash
of black eyes and dirty teeth and
shadows but every time it tried to
strike the Shadows there would be
nothing there and every time he got a
chance the old man would emerge from the
Shadows behind the shy guy to strike
back clawing into his flesh and
Vanishing again before the trapped Beast
could retaliate the nasty old sadist was
now starting to have some fun it was a
reflex test a classic game of high
stakes whack-a-mole and every time the
creature failed to strike him its
distress only seemed to grow this was
perfectly fine for the old man after all
he enjoyed a little mental torment as
much as he loved physical torture and a
human would have died or given in to
despair long before now this Monster's
wonderful mix of resilience and pain
made it a great chew toy the old man
kept up this routine baiting and
striking until something unanticipated
happened
he appeared waited for the swing
disappeared as it approached then
reappeared behind the shyy to deliver
another painful strike this time however
it seemed his victim had anticipated his
pattern before he could hit the creature
the shy guy turned quicker than anything
the old man had ever seen and hit him
with such Force he flew through several
walls in his own maze shattering them as
he went he hit the ground stunned by the
fact that the shy guy had actually
landed a hit but he wasn't done the sh
freaking monster came bounding after him
before the old man could stand it struck
him again and again and again pounding
his vile body into the ground which
cracked and crumbled the old man sneered
and sank into a puddle of his mucus on
the ground the old man was gone again SC
scp096 screamed in a mix of Rage Despair
and frustration so consumed with its
hunt that it didn't notice the pool of
corrosive mucus was slowly growing it
began to rise bubbling and hissing at
SCP 96's feet getting deeper and deeper
and deeper as the walls Rose taller and
taller around it the creature wailed
until a tide of the awful stuff reached
its face and cascaded down its throat
melting all the organs within as the
creature was fully submerged scp-106
manifested at top the wall and looked
down smiling spitefully he thought oh
you may have had me there boyo but in
the end I always always win nothing
could survive that and yet bubbles still
Rose from the slop below the old man
gritted his rotten teeth and balded his
fists in quiet anger moments later back
in our Dimension a portal opened in the
ground of SCP 96's Containment chamber
it vomited out scp096 skeleton smothered
in bubbling black goo and SCP 106 096
would probably be fully regenerated
within a couple of hours and if 682s
encounter with him was anything to go by
probably extremely unwilling to
interface with the old man and the old
man himself who couldn't help but feel a
little humiliated by the whole
experience was glad the two of them
would probably never meet again he left
the regenerating 096 and commenced the
Walk of Shame back to his containment
chamber they didn't even need the femur
breaker he just felt like having a sit
down and processing it all nobody else
would ever know what happened in the
pocket Dimension that day and for the
old old man's Pride that was probably
for the best but he'd know he'd always
know by the night's end he was sitting
in his containment chamber again for
lorely wondering God damn it Oldtimer
have you lost your Edge what does a
monster look like to you what figures
Slither and Claw their way into your
nightmares chasing you down endless
halls and stalking you through the dark
until you wake up screaming maybe you
imagine something tall and lean bony
arms reaching for you from a top
impossibly long slender legs its
featureless face showing no mercy maybe
you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers or a serial
killer in a hockey mask wielding a
machete maybe it's something more
inhuman a cosmic horror of tentacles and
eyes that can see into your very Soul
you probably don't think of something
with no arms no legs no body at all just
a face What's So Scary About That a face
can't run after you can't grab you by
the ankles and pull you under the bed a
face can only look it may be unsettling
to behold it might send a chill down
your spine but the worst it can do is
make you a little uncomfortable and if
you can't stand it any longer you could
always just close your eyes but walk
away and be done with it right if that's
what you think if you don't believe in
monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger then you're the type to
fall victim to a very special very
intelligent mask in the hollowed Halls
of the SCP Foundation there is a
containment cell outfitted with a
hermetically sealed glass case
surrounded by steel iron and Lead there
are guards posted outside along with a
trained psychologist if you are ever
Brave and foolish enough to enter that
room you'll see a simple white porcelain
comedy mask with a peculiar black
substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth whatever this slime touches
surfaces begin to corrode to rot away
into puddles of black liquid you might
notice the same liquid trickling slowly
down the walls of the room corrupting
everything in its path as as unsettling
of a sight as it is if you approach The
Mask to take a closer look you will find
yourself overcome by an intense nearly
irresistible urge to pick it up and put
it on to wear it to let it consume you
from the inside out and puppet your body
while your brain simply turns off like
an extinguished flame you'll simply be
gone then who knows what the mask will
will do it won't be your concern anymore
that's for sure but thankfully you
haven't gone into the room with the
porcelain mask you haven't let It cast
its spell on you not yet at least it's
waiting for you there in the room with
black slime oozing down its walls and it
will wait patiently for as long as it
needs to after all what's a mask without
a face to wear it SCP 035 better known
as the possessive mask sat in its
containment cell immobile as always it
didn't really have much of a choice in
the matter the foundation had chosen
selfishly to revoke its host privileges
once upon a time they offered it bodies
to choose from mannequins dummies and
wooden dolls it could Adorn and pilot it
didn't last as long as an organic living
host of course but it was something it
was a taste of freedom this Dreadful new
situation was almost enough to make the
mask want to change its surroundings
this Dreadful new situation was almost
enough to make the mask want to change
its expression from Comedy to tragedy
but it was determined to still find
something to laugh about even without a
body trapped in this infernal box there
had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment human Minds were
fragile things the mask had learned the
over the infinite years of its life if
one could call it a life apply the right
kind of pressure to the right weak
points whisper an enticing word or two
find the right emotional wound to
sprinkle a pinch of salt into and humans
would Buckle completely in almost no
time at all it had tried all sorts of
methods since being confined to this
boring little box sometimes it would
charm someone pour honeyed flattery into
to their heads until the person felt
like the mask was a dear friend a
confidant once suitable trust had been
built up the mask could persuade the
person to bring it a host or perhaps
even offer up themselves in sacrifice if
flattery didn't work there were other
potent approaches to take for a being
without ears the mask was a good
listener it picked up on things that no
human ever could the darkest Secrets
buried in a person's mind if it caught
wind of something especially juicy and
ruinous it could leverage that
threatened to expose an affair a crime
or perhaps something even worse
something
unspeakable if praise failed and so did
blackmail there was always good old
Supernatural intimidation all the mask
needed was for someone to be left alone
with it for a long enough period of time
then its invisible t generals could
snake out into their defenseless mind
weaving and poking around leaving a
lingering sense of cold dread of
incomprehensible Whispers in Long dead
tongues what a delight containment had
been in the early days when the
foundation had not yet figured out the
masks true capabilities when they would
leave security personnel with weak wills
and minimal training standing guard in
the m field of influence for hours at a
time as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free
will thanks to the helpers it had been
able to mold out of those hapless
victims they had been there to break
open its case and carry it to freedom
but every time the other guards thed the
attempts shooting its helpers and
rendering them utterly useless then the
foundation increased its security
something about the unacceptably high
homicide rates among staff assigned to a
cp035 how utterly boring how truly
pathetic still The Mask had found ways
to occupy itself even without any more
play things it had grown stronger with
its boredom stretching its influence
Beyond Organic beings and into the very
room itself its evil enriching and
deepening like a fine wine in the de of
a cold cellar over the months the walls
of SCP 035 is containment cell had begun
to secrete the same black slimy
substance that would pour from the
mask's eyes and mouth the liquid dripped
Down the Walls in deliberate formations
patterns that became increasingly easy
to recognize phrases in Italian Latin
ancient Greek all detailing ritual
sacrifices and mutilations The Mask took
time to describe described the
sacrificial victims in great detail
borrowing identifying traits from
various staff members so that it knew
would read the translations the walls
were slick with blood and harrowing
imagery and the glass case around the
mask was growing more and more Fragile
by the day anyone within 10 m of the
Mask could feel this strength too they
would leave the area complaining of
unintelligible Whispers of loud cruel
laughter and a lingering sense of nearly
insurmountable despair it was as if they
knew on some level that no one was truly
safe eventually The Mask would find a
way to come for them all the glass was
weakening and soon the mere thought of
Escape would make it shatter into pieces
then perhaps The Mask could finally get
its deepest desire
Revenge it wanted nothing more than to
try to make the foundation pay for
imprisoning it for taking away its host
privileges for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should
have had them falling to their knees in
worship the mask seeed with hatred day
in and day out it had seen the crumbling
of the Roman Empire the beheading of
Kings the decimation of armies it was
not going to be captured by a bunch of
rats in lab coats without dire
consequences befalling them maybe it
couldn't move from its prison cell at
the moment but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by dangerous
beasts capable of reducing the sight and
all who had dared to oppose the mask to
a pile of smoldering Rubble if it could
only find its way onto one of their
faces it would show them all just what
it was capable of as the piercing sound
of an alarm echoed down the hall the
sound of Screams and Chaos following
shortly after the masks frowning face
curved into a broad menacing smile what
was it that had escaped the lizard
perhaps the giant grinning man whatever
it was it seemed that the action was
heading right toward 035 containment
cell perhaps today was the day finally
the SC P Foundation would fall outside
the mask cell security officer Harper
was running for dear life though his
more rational mind knew he was living on
seconds not even minutes of borrowed
time his animal brain kept his legs
pumping desperately trying to avoid the
screaming howling Predator Hot on his
heels Harper looked over his shoulder
and screamed as a long white arm reached
for him scp096 the shy guy it's tooth
line jaw hanging low and foaming with
spittle that face that terrible terrible
face an absolute death sentence to all
who saw it he'd seen what he thought was
a crack in the otherwise perfect seal of
0 96's containment chamber but it could
have just as easily been a trick of the
light not even thinking he stepped
forward and looked at the vulnerability
in the chamber all it took was one
misplaced ray of light and he made out
the vague shape of a face in the
Darkness that's when the Weeping started
Harper knew in that moment his life was
over the correct thing to do would have
been to order everyone else in the room
to close their eyes while he stood there
and accepted his fate minimizing the
risk of spreading the damage further but
humans rarely have perfect reasoning
even less so when facing mortality back
in the present the shy guy made a
perfect lunge grabbing Harper and its
iron clutches and barreling through the
adjoining wall the nearby guards
scattered terrified keeping keeping
their eyes on the floor they might get a
slap on the wrist for temporarily
abandoning their posts but they weren't
going to die guarding some stupid evil
mask speaking of the possessive mask was
surprised to feel two new presences
enter its chamber through the now
destroyed wall these two presences soon
became just one as scp096 quickly and
totally annihilated security officer
Harper leaving nothing left the mask
couldn't see per se seeing as it had no
actual sensory organs but it felt around
this new guest with its many psychic
tendrils taking in this strange totality
the creature was powerful no doubt about
that and it elicit fear from those fools
at the SCP Foundation but the mask
noticed its brain waves were
extraordinarily muted humans to The
Masks vast and malicious Consciousness
weren't the sharpest kn in the drawer
but compared to this thing's mind they
were a pile of tempered katanas it
barely thought at all the mask would
have to dig deeper to find anything it
could use meanwhile scp096 finally began
to calm down the one who had seen it had
been annihilated bubbling rage was
slowly siphoned out and replaced by the
standard low but constant hum of anxiety
and despair it would wait until its head
was bagged and it was dragged back to
the dark same old same old all the way
to the end of time that's when it felt
something else it started as a faint
Buzz an unintelligible whisper and it
was almost like a door opened in the
back of its head something stepped in
and took a
seat can you hear me
stranger look
look I want to speak to you something
about felt the voice frightened and
comforted as CP 096 at the same time it
spoke with a greater degree of sympathy
than the creature had heard in a long
time and yet something about the way it
spoke implied evil in its
intent I know what you
want I know what you
fear wouldn't it be nice if they could
never look at you again
if you could cover that face of
yours I can help
you it will be so
simple all you need to do
is me on little by little 096 felt more
of these strange thoughts filling up the
emptiness in its head replacing the few
little thoughts the creature itself had
it felt felt itself lifting its hands
from the ground lifting them and
reaching towards something a glass box
the glass shattered and those long white
fingers reached for something within a
mask just like the voice had said a mask
to stop people from looking at its
face
yes yes you're doing so well you're so
close just a little further SC scp096
lifted The Mask to its face feeling
black liquid that burned its skin
dripping from the porcelain and put it
on and in that moment everything changed
the Shy Guy's body began to seize up
rattling as the mask Unleashed a web of
psychic tendrils through its body
mapping out across every inch like a new
nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to
sublimate oh this was going to be fun
for the first time the shy guy now under
the full control of the possessive mask
stood at full height on its hind legs
its spine and shoulders clicking into
place for its new stance The Mask
cracked its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin burning and fizzling with
the gooey black secretions but growing
back just as quickly the foundation had
every reason to fear it now a group of
security Personnel had gathered in the
Ragged hole where the chamber's north
wall used to be some were wielding light
firearms the guard at the front was
carrying an opaque black bag The Mask
laughed with its new body and turned to
the crowd the second they saw it on 0
96's body their faces fell for a moment
their bodies went slack with Terror this
situation was unprecedented what course
of action could they possibly take at a
time like this it looked at the bag held
by the leader of the security force and
projected a single thought into his
mind you won't be near
that before any of the guards even had a
chance to open fire The Mask lunged
forwards using the long terrible arms of
the shy guy to tear through the guards
they were dead in seconds their bodies
strewn about the hallway The Mask
porcelain was twisted into a wide
sadistic grin it could tell that it was
about to have some real fun around here
and once it slaughtered everyone here it
could finally stretch its legs out in
the open again true freedom to spread
misery fear and pain everywhere it went
there were just a few hundred members of
foundation Personnel it needed to turn
into corpses first more Containment
Breach alarm sounded around the site as
the mask began its Rampage running
through the hallways and tearing apart
any unfortunate Foundation personnal it
could get 0 96's Hands-On guards
researchers administrative staff
and even one extremely unlucky janitor
in hallway C6 it was having the time of
its long and terrible life and much to
its Glee it seemed that this new host's
body was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own turn
096 was indestructible but it was dumb
as a brick and had an easily exploitable
weakness get the bag on its head and
you're home free this new composite
creature was a different story it could
think tactically avoiding head-on
confrontations in favor of sneak attacks
and the monster had as much psychic
combat potential as physical guards
roving the building and teams heavily
armed with antimimetic protective gear
still reported feeling immense feelings
of psychological dread
overcomes that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to shreds the site director put out
an urgent call for all nearby mobile
task forces to intercept and help them
take care of the unfortunate situation
thankfully a Detachment of MTF 8 of10
also known as C no evil was operating on
a case in close proximity given their
specialization in anomalies with a m IC
visual property many on the team had
dealt with 096 breaches before that at
least gave them experience in half of
this situation and one operative among
them Sergeant henrique Ramirez would be
the one to bring this nightmare to an
end but it would cost him his life in
the process the mask was still using its
new indestructible body to wreck havoc
on the containment site once it had
taken out the primary contingents of
guards it was free to have its fun with
the rest stalking defenseless
researchers through the Halls making
sure to induce maximum Terror before
finally striking the killing blow every
single one of them died with a head full
of demonic Whispers it told them of the
mask's Eternal Dominion now it had found
the perfect host nothing on Earth would
stop it humans would be mere ants under
its feet 8 of 10 touched down and
entered the building Ramirez was
pointman leading the others into the
bowels of the blood drenched containment
site they had been briefed on what they
were heading in for 096 and 035 had
reached symbiosis and were displaying
unprecedented anomalous effects enter
with Extreme Caution they're beyond
dangerous even more so together than
alone ideally Ramirez would have wanted
to go in with a comprehensive plan but
lives were on the line here they needed
to leap off the cliff and build their
wings on the way down it was only when
they finally en Ed the monster that they
realized just how outmatched they were
despite their best efforts the combined
speed intelligence and ferocity of the
mask's new form allowed it to make short
work of 8 of 10 only Ramirez was left
heavily injured even if a miracle
happened he knew he wasn't getting out
of here alive The Mask grabbed him with
one of 0 96's Claws and lifted him up it
would take its time with this one make
him suffer watch him squirr worm destroy
his mind Ramirez felt The Masks psychic
tendrils penetrate the membrane of his
mind those Whispers those terrible
Whispers reciting all his worst fears
with terrible Glee his gun was out of
ammo his knife was broken all he had
left on him was a pocket mirror and that
was his Eureka moment it was a long shot
but it was also his only shot he reached
out and grabbed the bottom of the Mask
pulling for dear life knif his other
hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror opening its lid with a deaf
flick of his thumb it was too fast for
the master to even register what was
going on Ramirez forced his eyes shut
and lifted up the mirror the mask saw
its own reflection in the glass as the
bottom of its face came loose revealing
the reflection of the face underneath
the mask squeezed killing Ramirez but it
was already too late it had finally seen
the face of its host and that would cost
it dearly The Mask felt a sudden and
tremendous push back to its psychic
forces a blind Despair and then rage
that choked out everything scp096 began
to sob and howl somehow the mask was no
longer in control despite its psychic
protests 096 reached up and tore the
terrible mask from its face tossing it
against the wall with such force that it
was embedded in the brick work its last
thoughts as other mobile task force
operators descended on the area to bag
096 and return it to its containment
chamber were what the hell just happened
and the next thought that crossed the
mind of the site director was request
site transfer for 035 as soon as
possible don't want to repeat of this
incident anytime soon well hello there
SCP fans let's get this out of the way
first you've seen the title and
thumbnail and you're probably wondering
wait is siren head an SCP and the answer
is is no siren head is not an SCP it's a
freaky internet monster created by
renowned Canadian horror artist Trevor
Henderson your next question is probably
what's with this crazy looking server
Bank behind me allow me to introduce you
to the
anamatronic exclusively by the SCP
Foundation it's capable of a whole bunch
of interesting features calculating
ideal containment methods running State
of-the-art Foundation WebCrawler
software making an editing fun SCP
YouTube videos but the most interesting
feature that the
anamatronic with data fed into it by
thousands of real life experiments
conducted by the SCP Foundation it's
going to save countless dollars and
lives for foundation researchers but way
more importantly it's going to let us
explore all kinds of weird and wacky
what if scenarios that would never
happen organically could SCP 343 beat
Goku or Superman who's a deadly or
Supernatural killer SCP 106 or Freddy
Krueger would the world simply explode
from adorableness if SCP 999 and baby
Yoda ever crossed those multiversal
barriers and met we can explore all of
these questions along with any others
you may have down in the comments
seriously comment it we dare you but to
get things started we figured we'd make
the
linkiest nightmare monster scp096
against the internet's Trevor
Henderson's siren head sorry Slenderman
you're just not cool anymore so without
further Ado let's kick the
anamatronic and Elliott a pair of
aspiring travel YouTubers from
California we're taking a vacation to
the Pacific Northwest to spend some time
in the area's beautiful Lush Forest
forests however while the duo were both
big fans of travel for its own sake they
weren't just here for the trees and
fresh air you see despite their jet
setting lifestyle Ricky and Elliott's
subscribers and Views hadn't exactly
been phenomenal lately turns out hiking
Vlogs and GoPro footage of the two of
them jumping into absurdly blue water
and Bali weren't exactly that
interesting to people who weren't
actually there but Ricky had formulated
an ingenious plan to pull the two of
them out of obscurity they would hunt
down and film real footage of the
legendary siren head a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards there were plenty of
fakers out there on YouTube but if the
two of them could get real footage of
siren head and also preferably survive
the experience they'd be framing their
golden play buttons in no time but they
were already encountering certain issues
for starters the two Californians had
severely underestimated just how cold it
was in the Pacific Northwest and as such
were already shivering from from bone
deep cold the second issue was food
while the two of them had thought ahead
and brought a selection of tasty protein
bars they'd also gotten hungry during
the early hours of their walk and eaten
all of them leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner
rolled around and the third and perhaps
most problematic issue of all was the
fact that Ricky and Elliot didn't
exactly have a great sense of direction
during all of their previous trips
they'd been on guided tours with local
experts in this instance wanting to take
all the siren head glory and Cloud for
themselves they decided to come in alone
with the incredibly janky Google Maps
app to guide them as such as the night
was creeping in the two aspiring YouTube
celebrities had no idea where they were
needless to say it wasn't exactly an
ideal situation and to make matters
worse Ricky and Elliot had been
experiencing some strange feelings for
the last couple of hours when they'd
gotten particularly deep into the forest
that dread inducing sensation of being
watched by something lurking just out of
sight a gaze with some unknowable and
Darkly malicious intent boiling behind
it these two poor saps had no idea what
was in store for them tonight and
wouldn't you know it the one watching
them right now wouldn't even be the only
monster after them after an expectable
amount of bumbling and buffoonery Ricky
and Elliot managed to gather up enough
Tinder to make a semi- reses campfire
they could sleep out here tonight then
set off in search of siren head or
civilization whichever came first in the
daylight the next day the duo did what
they could to remain chipper in spite of
the ominous circumstances sure they were
trapped in the depths of the woods alone
but think of the amazing Vlog footage
they'd get they'd be like the next Blair
Witch crew except they'd live hopefully
but as the duo sat next to their
campfire they felt that ominous
sensation again the hairs on the back of
their neck started standing up they felt
Shivers that didn't just come from the
cold more and more they started to feel
certain that something in this forest
was watching them something ancient and
powerful and evil that's when they heard
The Telltale crackle of radio static and
their skeletons almost jumped out of
their skin could it be him the patron
saint of Gone Missing without a trace of
creeping dread of bad things coming
siren head himself both men fell Sil ENT
all they could hear was the crackling of
their own fire had the sound before just
been an illusion a product of a pair of
paranoid Minds also predisposed to sense
siren headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees they'd been reading about a
higher rate of disappearances in this
area along with a number of frightening
sightings of tall thin beings and
radiostatic that seemed perfectly
consistent with siren head activity
that's why they'd come here in the first
place but had they come here to their
deaths the two needed to distract
themselves or they'd go mad from the
paranoia they decided to share a few fun
little anecdotes of the travels they had
had before meeting one another showing
the photos they'd saved on their
smartphones Ricky had been to Hawaii
Tahiti borabora Fiji St Lucia and the
malds clearly he liked his vacations
warm and Sandy Elliot on the other hand
tended to like his trips to be a little
more adventurous he'd seen volcanoes
waterfalls deep and treacherous caves
systems and of course a little guided
mountaineering one photo that Elliot
showed Ricky was particularly
breathtaking he was standing in the
foreground of a snowy landscape with an
incredible mountain range behind him
when Ricky asked Elliot where exactly
he'd taken this picture strangely enough
he drew a complete blank maybe somewhere
in Canada or Siberia or something like
that but it was a hell ofet Tri whatever
the case he remembered having a great
time it was such a tiny detail but when
looking at the photo Ricky couldn't help
but notice something in the background a
speck of white sure not exactly
newsworthy in the snowy mountain range
but this wasn't snow it was a speck of
white that seemed to be a slightly
different shade than the rest of the
mountain strange perhaps it was just
some tiny particle stuck on the lens
whenever the photo was taken the two
continued to chat and warmed their hands
against the fire having no idea of the
horror they just awoken in doing so over
100 miles away at an SCP Foundation
containment site researchers and guards
walked around the perimeter of a huge
airtight metal cube reading off
Diagnostics and audio recordings for
reasons that should be obvious to
everyone who's a fan of this channel
there were no camera feeds coming from
the inside of the great metal cube only
a faint whimpering sound like a sad
wounded animal and the clanking of
pacing feet moving back and forth over
the metal dragging forlorn Knuckles it
turned every head in the room room when
the crying started to get louder soon it
wasn't just quiet weeping it was a
series of horrendous slobbering sobs
whales of pure pain and despair someone
in the room screamed close your eyes and
hit the deck knowing exactly what had
happened they learned well enough from
the infamous incident
0961 Containment Breach that there was
no way of stopping this thing until itd
run its course the best they could do
was minimize their own fatalities in the
process everyone in the room did did as
they were told hitting the ground
closing their eyes and covering them
with their hands just to be safe that's
when the solid steel of the cube was
torn open like CP paper and the howling
raging scp096 Broke Free Galloping on
all fours through the nearest wall
shattering it and spraying debris
everywhere as mobile task forces were
dispatched should track the rampaging
Abomination and try their best to glue
the path ahead as it sought out its
Target one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room
woe be tied the poor fools who saw that
Monster's face back in the deep dark
forests of the Pacific Northwest the
presence of some unnerving force was
becoming far harder to deny for Ricky
and Elliot they heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the woods the
squeals and crackles of radiostatic they
saw shapes moving amongst the trees tall
and thin like long spindly limbs while
neither wanted to voice Their Fear they
were both thinking similar things if
their there really was a monster out
here why hadn't it killed them it had
all the Time in the World to do it but
that was just it wasn't it it had all
the time in the world so why rush it had
every Advantage it could take its time
and do this exactly how it wanted to
Ricky and Elliot had made themselves the
perfect prey and as they saw huge lith
figure suddenly separate itself from the
trees they began to wonder if it was
really worth it to risk both of their
lives for YouTube Club out either way it
was now probably too late for regrets
Ricky and Elliot's Jaws fell in horror
as the monster emerged from the darkness
before them they recognized the awful
model skin stretched over the monster's
40t frame they saw the grasping hands
and up above the nightmarish faceless
head split into a pair of sirens
pointing in different directions each
one filled with nashing teeth and
slithering tongues it was even more
terrifying than they could possibly have
imagine mentioned siren head speakers
crackled into life and hissed out 9 18 1
child 17 remove
V Ricky and Elliot stumbled backwards as
siren head advanced IT speaker still
bleeding hateful static neither could
move or speak only watches its long
gnarled fingers reach from the dark to
grasp them there was a terrible pained
whale in the woods after that but it
wasn't coming from Ricky Elliot or siren
head it was distant at first but soon
became louder and louder as the Force's
point of origin came barreling towards
them even siren head couldn't help but
turn to see scp096 a flash of terrible
white Fury come charging towards them in
the dark knocking down all the trees in
its path leaves and pine needles
scattered trunks exploded into splinters
nothing would stop the shy guy from
claiming its prey nothing would stop it
from destroying Ricky and now as it
approached Elliot made the Fatal mistake
of looking at its face too 096 lunge
ready to go in for the kill when siren
head's hands closed around the shy guy
slender torso in one fluid motion with
surprising strength for its scrawny
build it hurled the shy guy into the
distance smashing another several trees
in its path the words my PR my PR mine
mine
mine pissed out of its speakers but 096
was only down for mere moments it sprung
back up on its hind and four legs and
started Galloping towards Ricky and
Eliot again who were still frozen in
place this time just before the shy guys
terrible claws could close around the
two hapless wannabe YouTubers down came
siren head's clenched fist pounding 0
96's head into the dirt overhead mobile
task force helicopter circled wearing
their scramble goggles and trying to get
a visual on the situation unfolding
below they could hardly believe what
they were seeing down there with some
other unclassified anomaly managing to
intercept 096 in its rage state only a
handful of anomalies on record have ever
been shown of being capable of such a
feat it seemed that they were dealing
with something serious here down below
the battle continued siren head had a
unique advantage over most other
combatants facing scp096 it was an
extradimensional being with no eyes
merely an innate psychic awareness of
its victims around it it not unlike how
scp096 detect people seeing its face in
photographs or videos without need for
any kind of direct contct as such it was
impossible for siren head to see the shy
guy's face and thus impossible for the
shy guy to ever actually direct its
aggression against it whether or not 096
would kill steel siren head's intended
prey was another matter entirely in the
night's first minor miracle Ricky and
Elliot remembered that they'd been born
with working legs and decided that right
now would be an excellent time to use
them they turned and began to run while
siren head continued beating the shy guy
into the dirt sprinting with all their
might however the growing distance
between them only aggravated the shy guy
further it sprang out from the dirt with
unstoppable force and broke away from
siren head's grip the shy guy never
wasted time ever it always made a beine
for its intended victim with one
directive in mind total Annihilation
tonight is no different Ricky and Elliot
screamed as they heard its pounding
Gallop on the ground behind them closer
closer closer then suddenly defying all
spatial reasoning siren head emerged out
from the darkness between Ricky Elliot
and 096 being 40 ft tall siren head
dwarfed even the shy guy it lunged and
grabbed the Wailing white monstrosity
holding it as one would a particularly
vicious cat and trying to keep it in
place siren had wanted to crush the
monster's bones and carry on stalking
its feeble human prey who were currently
in the the process of getting away but
somehow that was impossible it was
almost like the monster had an
indestructible skeleton up above the mle
task forces continued observing this
Clash of the Titans from their two
helicopters seeing how siren head was
somehow doing a serviceable job of
subduing the shy guy one of the task
force members joked maybe we should hire
this guy another chimed in I don't think
we have any ballistic vests in his size
the laughter soon turned to screams when
siren had hurled 096 his flailing body
up at one of the helicopters with
Incredible Force knocking it out of the
sky it greened down to the ground a ball
of fear and violence before exploding
anyone who survived the initial blast
was unlucky enough to have seen the shy
guys face their screams rang out briefly
before being abruptly silenced by the
monster helicopter Alpha had no
survivors meanwhile Ricky and Elliott
had kept running until their lungs
burned and their muscles pumped
thumbtacks seeing that the chaos was so
far behind them now they took a moment
to stop and breathe recomposing
themselves in the second minor miracle
of the night it looked like the two of
them had actually survived this ordeal
those two horrific monsters had canceled
each other out but Ricky and Elliot were
about to learn a harsh lesson they
really weren't that lucky the last thing
the two of them ever saw was siren head
emerging from the darkness once more the
last thing they ever felt was the
monster's terrible gnarled fingers
curling around their bodies too fast for
them to escape and the last thing they
ever heard was each other's screams
followed by a sickeningly meaty crunch
elsewhere in the forest as scp096 is
whales died down to its usual mudlin SOB
the rage state had ended all of its
targets had been destroyed it just
hadn't been the one to do all of the
destroying per se not long after that
helicopter Bravo descended safely and
the remaining MTF members closed around
the blubbering Beast someone black
bagged it and everyone breathed a sigh
of relief knowing that was at least one
monster taken care of tonight what about
the other one the MTF Lieutenant asked
the team's Commander shook his head and
said uh let's worry about that freak
later and get 096 back to containment
this place gives me the creeps hello one
and all and welcome back to the
anamatronic for projecting any seemingly
improbable scenario for your viewing
Indulgence and today we decided to do
something slightly different with it
here at SCP explained we usually
activate the anomet to bring encounters
between the anomalous denisons of the
SCP universe and other fictional
characters like Doctor Strange fighting
the Scarlet king or able crossing paths
with Batman but this
anamatronic the shy guy was tricked into
entering the input Booth of the
anomalous refiner machine during a
Containment Breach what emerged was
maybe the handsomest man to ever live
Beautiful both on the outside and within
a lot of our comments pointed out that
this refined version of 096 felt akin to
a gigachad and that got us thinking what
if scp096 was to encounter the real
gigachad well the
anamatronic one or as we like to call it
the obvious outcome pits the thin
humanoid anomaly Against The Man Behind
the meme Ernest kov is a Russian fitness
trainer and model forever immortalized
in the animals of Internet history by a
series of black and white photoshopped
pictures that garnered him the nickname
of gigachad thanks to his Practically
Perfect 90° jawline and muscular
physique kov seemingly unknowingly
became the archetype for the Ultram
masculine handsome man however The Man
Behind the gigachad meme is still just a
man man the infamous photos of him were
heavily edited for an art project known
as Sleek in tears and while Ernest does
Sport some impressive muscles from all
his time at the gym that strength isn't
enough to save him from the shy guy
after all he is still just a man
according to the
anamatronics the most likely outcome if
the two were ever to meet would end
pretty similarly to the Grim fate of
many others who have gazed upon the face
of scp096 the moment Ernest looks at the
creature he would in all likelihood
activate 0 96's rage State his physique
and above average level of Fitness might
give him a slight Advantage allowing him
to perhaps outrun the shy guy for longer
than most but ultimately Ernest kov
would be able to run but not hide from
scp096 the creature would track him down
and hone in on him with anomalous speed
dispatching him before returning to its
usual docile sobbing State the result
and SCP p096 Victory now we know what
you're thinking is that really it we had
the same reaction too but hold on for a
minute after giving the machine an
additional set of variables we were able
to get a few more interesting outcomes
out of the
anamatronic 2 shy harder of course
Ernest kov might be the face of an
internet meme and ultimately just a very
strong Russian man in comparison to the
anomalous traits of scp096
but the gigachad the gigachad is more
than a man so much more than the sum of
his Parts existing within the online
zagge since as early as 2017 the
gigachad is far more powerful than a
mere mortal he doesn't just represent
idealized standards of overe exaggerated
masculinity like the Action Movie heroes
of the 1980s the gigachad embodies those
ideas he is the very notion of a
physically perfected human spe specimen
given form you may not like it but Peak
Performance doesn't even come close to
the gigachad and neither does scp096
even at the top of its game the creature
quite literally pales in comparison to
its imposing opponent in scenario 2 shy
harder the
anamatronic that if the two were to meet
the scales would tip in the complete
opposite direction from the first
outcome for that was scp096 against the
man but against the meme him himself
well this fight is no contest as a
matter of fact it's hardly even a fight
certainly not a fair one and instead is
more of an execution from the moment the
Unstoppable Tower of muscle and perfect
angular jawline that is the gigachad
clasps eyes on scp096 it's practically
the beginning of the end the shy guy
doesn't even lift bro but gigachad can
bench 1 million times his own body
weight in his sleep so when SCP p096
comes racing towards him intent on
killing him just for looking at its
screeching wide jawed face the gigachad
does what the gigachad does best he
lifts grabbing a scp096 with ease as it
comes to him screeching gigachad
casually hoists the creature off the
ground although he's only using the
tiniest portion of his immense and
Infinite Strength it's more than enough
Force to send the shy guy soaring
upwards crashing through multiple
ceilings as it sent hurdling up the
numerous floors of the foundation
facility above of course being lifted is
hardly going to kill the shy guy
outright the creature is known to be
invulnerable after all but it's not like
gigachad can go down easily either don't
forget this is no mere mortal but an
internet meme incarnate and on the
internet nothing ever dies his Perpetual
existence as part of online history
aside the gigachad is so strong that no
doubt his abs could withstand the fire
power of any conventional weapon
realizing that even if it could reach
him it couldn't even scratch the
gigachad scp096 would undoubtedly begin
a downward spiral the shy guy is a
creature so insecure in itself and its
appearance that it kills anyone who so
much as glances at its face in photos so
being presented with the living
embodiment of an idea it could never
even hope to attain the biceps the
perfect right angled jawline it's all
too much sending scp096 into a complete
meltdown the creature would be
neutralized once and for all by the very
existence of the gigachad resulting in
his victory okay so we're one point to
scp096 and one to gigachad and most
people would maybe consider leaving it
there but not us we wanted more than
that you see we quickly realized that
the anamatronic scenario was based on a
lot of earlier iterations of the
gigachad meme don't get us wrong that
version of the ultimate man could still
easily destroy the shy guy but around
March of 2021 the infamous photoshopped
images of erns kov started to be used in
slightly different formats that's the
thing about memes they're not only
Immortal forever logged in the ancient
texts of the Wayback machine and
compilation videos here on YouTube but
memes are also adaptable they can evolve
and change finding new variations as
time goes on as such the average fan
versus average enjoyer meme saw a new
use of the gigachad before the gigachad
this notion of the ideal Ultra masculine
specimen was based on let's be honest
some pretty outdated ideas about what it
means to be a man after all it takes
more than muscle to be a man not every
man or masculine presenting person has
to work out until they're built like a
brick wall perhaps the real Measure of a
Man is how sincere sensitive and
supportive you can be as well as
standing by your interests rather than
caving to Old societal standards of
masculinity and after we updated our
data the
anamatronic outcome or what we like to
call scenario 3 the average scp096
enjoyer in this projection the Giga
Chad's true strength isn't just his
masculine physique and his unattainable
standards instead it's in part the
inherent adaptability of his status as a
meme but also his compassion just like
before he's more than able to resist as
CP 096 is attacks and the creature's
insecurity comes out put on full display
when presented with gigachad sharp
jawline but rather than overcome his
anomalous adversary by fighting him this
scenario sees the gigachad comforting
the shy guy through calm empathy and
words of affirmation he reminds scp096
that true acceptance of ones self comes
from within and that message strikes a
cord with the creature in a turn of
events none of us saw coming the
gigachad offers to help scp096 overcome
his crippling and deadly sense of
insecurity the pair start using the
on-site gym together after hours when
there aren't any innocent Foundation
Personnel around there Giga Chad not
only offers to introduce scp096 to an
exercise regimen if that's what the
creature wants but also helps the shy
guy work on his confidence
they form a friendship with scp096
taking a liking to working out not
because it wants to be buff like its new
friend the gigachad but more so because
doing so makes it feel more comfortable
in its own skin scp096 gradually starts
to like itself more even eating
healthier thanks to Giga Chad's advice
eventually the shy guy begins looking
far more content and even starts to
develop self-confidence it's not often
that a story involving SCP 09 six exists
with the creature getting to achieve
some semblance of Happiness well there
is one that comes to mind the very same
Shy Guy story that sent us on this
particular streak of pitting it against
the gigachad in the first place but what
if we put them together would coming
across a refined scp096 spell the N for
the gigachad or would the muscular
masculine meme undo the Shy Guy's
previous happy ending well according to
the
last left him after being turned into a
handsome 9-ft tall man scp096 had just
started going by the name David SCP 978
the desired camera had been used to
photograph the refined Shy Guy it showed
him holding hands with the foundation
scientist responsible for his
transformation who had studied the new
and improved scp096 in great detail she
had quite the understanding of him but
perhaps the photograph from the desire
camera was more of a metaphor than what
SC scp096 or David really desired wasn't
specifically the researcher who' studied
him but a partner who understood him
someone to call an equal enter the
gigachad according to the calculations
made by the
anamatronic of ultimate masculinity both
strong and sensitive came bursting into
the foundation facility there the moment
he and David saw each other was like the
meeting of an Unstoppable force and an
immovable object neither other one
rushed to solve the encounter with
violence both the gigachad and scp096
appreciated each other's aesthetic
appeal both were remarkably handsome and
one couldn't bear the thought of ridding
the world of the other instead it was
love at first sight both David formerly
known as scp096 and the gigachad fell
head over heels in love with each other
and looking at both it was not hard to
see why they were a pair of fine
perfectly chiseled fellas and they
instantly hit it off the newly
established couple enjoyed each other's
company spending time in deep
conversations scp096 introducing his new
partner to his friends at the foundation
while gigachad was comfortable with his
own masculinity to express his feelings
towards David without fear or judgment
no relationship is perfect of course for
a short time a sliver of David's old
self reemerged the shy guy in him
worried that perhaps his relationship
with the gigachad was based pure purely
on both of their extreme good looks and
was nothing more than superficial but by
being an embodiment of healthy idealized
masculinity the gigachad was able to
sense something was wrong with David and
rather do the insecure thing of letting
it Fester he addressed it directly and
they discussed the issue in a healthy
mature and constructive way not just so
they could put scp096 is worry to rest
but so that both of them could further
strengthen their relationship and grow
as people and of course gigachad wasn't
just attracted to scp096 as refined good
looks far from being superficial he
recognized that David was a complete
person beautiful both inside and out and
loved him as a whole not just because
they were both conventionally attractive
on the surface scp096 and the gigachad
stayed together for the rest of their
lives or as we decided to name this
fourth scenario from the
a group of well-armed mobile task force
members entered the containment chamber
armed to the teeth some faced the ground
droplets of sweat dripping onto their
visors some wore Dr Dan's Infamous
scramble goggles and one particularly
Brave member of personnel wielded only a
bag the room they were currently
standing in was perhaps the most
dangerous place in the world why because
it contained two terrifying Titans of
the anomalous World SCP 682 the
infinitely hateful hard to destroy
reptile and scp096 the shy guy the
ultimate mindless killing machine and if
the very idea of having them in the same
place doesn't feel risky enough the
deadly Duo had just spent 27 hours in
one of the most brutal brawls imaginable
and incidentally fights like this are
exactly why we're here today we cover a
lot of scps on this channel and we've
seen the ways some of the most dangerous
anomalies out there can tear their way
through civilians and train Foundation
MTF operatives with with ease but how do
they fare against Monsters maniacs and
reality Benders their own size with the
help of the SCP explained audience we're
going to explore theoretical fights
between some of the anomalous world's
biggest badasses and who better to get
this show on the road than two of the
most iconic and deadly monsters that
haunt the halls of a foundation
containment site near you the hardto
destroy reptile and the shy guy are
household names for anyone familiar with
the SCP Foundation and before we get
into the gruesome results of their first
fight and your theories about how a
potential rematch might play out let's
get to know the combat progress of this
pair of nasty customers what kind of
damage are they capable of taking and
inflicting spoiler alert it's a hell of
a lot in this corner we have SCP 682 a
monster whose ability to survive
seemingly anything is only equal by its
terrible attitude towards pretty much
everyone and everything around it though
to be fair you'd probably be a little
grumpy too if the SCP Foundation was
constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained 682s basic offensive power
set involves impressive strength speed
intelligence and the aid of its deadly
fangs claws and tail however 682 is
considerably stronger after it's just
survived and regenerated from a
termination attempt that's because the
true combat asset of 682 is and always
has been its adaptability specifically
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a
state of near death but doesn't finish
the job 682 will generally either
develop a perfect defense or counter
offensive for that attack or somehow add
a version of the attack to its own
Arsenal this has ranged from Super
pressurized Jets of its own blood
dangerously radioactive banana beams
firing out of its mouth and even an
incapacitating laughter blast gained
from an encounter with the adorable as
CP 999 it is an absolute Swiss army
knife of dangerous anomalous powers and
ability abilities and if you need any
further proof of that check out our
multiple videos on all the ludicrous
failed attempts to kill this nightmare
lizard and in this corner we've got
scp096 the shy guy while 682 is
freakishly adaptable in most situations
sccp 096 is pretty much Unstoppable this
long gangly creep will murder anyone who
sees even the tiniest glimpse of its
face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain it does
this by entering what many call its rage
State activated by the sudden immense
distress of its face being seen when it
enters this state the SCP Foundation has
only one prerogative get themselves and
anyone else out of its way because you
will not stop this thing until it's
killed its Target all the SCP Foundation
has ever been able to do is wait until
after the target has been obliterated
and then come in to bag its head when it
enters its docile State almost nothing
else has even successfully slowed it
down while they have been capable of
damaging its flesh the monster skeleton
seems to be utterly indestructible and
its damaged flesh has proven
consistently able to grow back the
monster seems to be immune to everything
from Pain to cold and moves at such a
speed that it's pretty much impossible
to escape for long so when you factor in
an indestructible body a men's strength
a men's speed and an Unstoppable urge to
kill anyone who sees its face you're
looking at a formidable opponent it's
only natural that the foundation would
want to used 096 in their 682 cross
tests so what exactly happened when the
mobile task force entered the room after
this first epic battle what did they
find inside the chamber in the grizzly
aftermath scp096 lay crumpled in the
corner wheezing scared covered in its
own blood 682 was barely recognizable
096 had reduced it to a quarter of its
original size the rest having been
utterly torn to shreds both had narrowly
survived the encounter but it was an
epic battle neither of them would ever
forget though this was especially true
for scp096 you see as we alluded to
earlier SCP 682 is used to taking a
kicking at this point it hasn't ever
truly been killed but it's been beaten
eaten burned Zapped and smashed within
an inch of its life more times than you
can count 096 on the other hand was not
used to not being able to utterly
eliminate its prey while it is
impossible to speculate what's going on
inside scp's 0 96's mind all evidence
points towards getting a draw in this
battle seriously damaging SCP 96's
confidence now every time Foundation
Personnel tries to bring 096 into 682s
containment chamber he begins crying and
scratching at his own face why is he
scared of 682 is he humiliated thinking
of the fight he wasn't able to win or is
the very idea of someone seeing his face
and him not being able to immediately
kill them just to unbearably stressful
seeing as the shy guy mouth is only good
for two things and neither of them are
for talking we'll never truly know but
either way it's clear that 096 has no
interest in a rematch but what if that
changed what if 096 realized that it was
wasting its potential it managed to get
SCP 682 3/4 of the way to death last
time what could stop it from getting
that last quarter sure nothing has ever
killed SCP 682 before but there's a
first time for everything right maybe
096 would have a rocky style training
montage where he rebuilds his confidence
and becomes the underdog he was always
meant to be he'd walk right up to that
big nasty reptile and give him the
rematch of the century what would happen
then now we give the floor to you the
loyal viewers of SCP explained here are
some of your thoughts theories and
opinions on a potential historic rematch
between these two creeps let's get ready
to
rumble I really wanted an excuse to say
that oo I really like saying that Pingu
with an ax said if 682s adaptability is
based around his ability to develop
counter measures to any damage inflicted
or in the case of 173 a countermeasure
to the cause of said damage I imagine
682 would turn his skin entirely
reflective causing 096 to see his own
face and the feedback loop would break
his mind H interesting whether this
would work is all dependent on whether
scp096 can actually see or if it is
merely capable of psychically intuiting
when someone else sees its face if the
latter is true then this particular
adaptation wouldn't do much good for SCP
682 random user said if this is after
their first cross test and they were
forced to interact again they wouldn't
attempt to fight each other I feel like
they'd form a truce and take out the
researchers on site yeah this would be
one of the worst case scenarios whether
even the SCP Foundation could handle a
simultaneous 682 and 096 breach without
bringing in hammer down is an open
question Raman vonin said simple after
the first encounter when 096 stopped
attacking 682 682 will grow eyes that
filter out 0 96's face the next time
organic scramble goggles Dr Dan would be
fuming with jealousy coup Sader said I
really want scp096 to win so I'm sending
him a blind personal trainer so he can
beat the snot out of SCP 682 this is
exactly the kind of help scp's 096 needs
he's got the rage endurance and strength
with a little help getting his form and
technique in order he'd be an even more
formidable opponent hior Rio said I'd
like to imagine 096 after playing with
682 for so long would try to eat 682 in
a vain attempt to kill it only to gain
682s abilities and vice versa either of
these options would be horrifying scp096
with 682 abilities or 682 with 0 96's
abilities would likely be a true truly
perfect killing machine that's
terrifying Autumn said what if they just
shared a nice cold drink while playing
Mario Kart I'm sure 096 would be the
white Shy Guy character in every race
personally we love this idea and we
think 682 would go for Bowser I
personally go for Luigi ibraim timour
said 682 would win eventually it's way
more intelligent adaptive and overall
malicious while 096 a just on Instinct
this is undeniably a good point with 682
lack and sheer Savage it makes up for in
its ruthless calculating intelligence
could this give it the edge over 096
monoy Mukerji said that fight would be
interesting because both of them now
know how they attack and what their
attacks are nice segue due to the
relatively mindless nature of 096 as far
as we're aware it's probably unable to
learn from experience 682 however would
have the advantage of knowing how 096
operates in the Second Battle Devon
Smith said as much as I'd like to see
how this would play play out I imagine
096 can't manage more than other scps
have in the past not to downplay him but
he might need some extra friends to do a
whole lot more damage it's undeniable
that going in with tag team partners
would better 0 96's chances of taking
the lizard down however due to scp096 is
shyness and tendency to kill everyone
and everything that looks at him he
doesn't have many friends looking to
volunteer nales said 096 will cry in the
corner while 682 starts attacking it
eventually it gets confused that 096
isn't fighting back after an hour and
begins to adapt to it and becomes docile
forever okay look while it's unlikely
that this would happen it's certainly
nice to imagine isn't it Adam Brittain
said narratively it needs to conclude
with a reason to never try it again so
I'm going to say that 682 will
telepathically project the image of 096
into the sight staff or the entire human
psychop space ooh yikes this is a
possibility so terrifying and honestly
plausible that it's making us regret
wanting to see this rematch all together
chaos Insurgency said I think 682 would
just think for damn's sake just leave me
alone given he's been through more
termination attempts than SCP 5031 can
count on its fingers who could blame him
for getting a little frustrated Michael
Porter said I think that 682 and 096
would take each other to court for
aggravated assault against the other
either one of them will get sentenced to
death and will unsurprisingly not die or
the two team up to kill the entire
courtroom and they walk out as a new
serial killing team the real question is
what kind of lawyers would represent a
pair of murderous anomalous monsters in
court Better Call Saul Ari Workman said
maybe if we try being nice to them for
once we can offer them a cup of tea and
get them both a therapist 682 will talk
all his hate away and then realize his
wrongdoing and become an activist and
096 would become very confident about
his face and become a model there
problem solved hey when people strive
towards self-improvement we're all
winers ERS but we don't know if we can
say the same for 682 and
096 even if this rematch ever did happen
perhaps it'd be just another draw an
Unstoppable Force against an immovable
object but other matchups may be more
clearcut what kind of versus battles
would you like to see us cover in the
future what scps would you really love
to see duke it out let us know in the
comments and keep an eye out on the
community posts in order to throw in
your anomalous two cents for our next
versus Battle somehow now most likely
through some nefarious means a fateful
postcard has been sent to one of the
residents of the murky Mysterious aranam
Island living on this particular Island
was already a strange and scary enough
existence given the horrors the
inhabitants of anaram share their home
with but perhaps the only thing just as
horrible as life on that island was
being sent a postcard sure that doesn't
sound all that horrible postcards are
used usually used to show a corner of
the world far away and extend well-
wishes from friends or relatives on
vacations but ordinarily postcards don't
depict a photo of scp096 with the words
wish he was there scrolled on the other
side from its containment cell at the
SCP Foundation the shy guy instantly
sensed that somebody somewhere had seen
a picture of its face breaking down into
an enraged fit of homos idal in security
scp096 immediately broke from its
containment chamber and made a
CrossCountry beine heading straight for
arinum at anomalously accelerated speeds
little did the creature or the
foundation know that the shy guy was
being led straight into a trap and the
poor island resident who had received
the chilling postcard well they were
unlucky enough to be the bait while the
SCP Foundation started frantically
trying to track down where it had gone
the shy guy had already made its way to
a wooden cabin belonging to the
unfortunate postcard recipient emerging
from the now emptied home once the owner
was no more scp096 would have returned
to his cell just as quickly as he left
that is if he wasn't the only monstrous
creature on the island a loud and sudden
noise caught the creatures attention the
sound of an old steam train whistle it
rang out once more from somewhere off in
the distance but there was so much thick
fog hanging in the air around arinum
that it was almost impossible to see
anything especially with how dark it was
the second time the whistle sounded it
was closer but there was another sound
too and not the loud chugging of a steam
engine that you would expect it was an
erratic heavy thuing the noise of lots
of something drumming against the ground
causing the Earth itself to shutter legs
they were the steps of multiple huge
legs crawling across the surface of the
island heading straight towards scp096 a
third piercing whistle rang out even
closer still this time the orange glow
of a light could be seen dulled by the
surrounding fog but getting brighter and
clearer as it came closer the light was
casting Shadows against the dark fog
long spinley shapes of spidery appendage
until before the Shy Guy's eyes a
creature of pure nightmares came
bursting out of the fog it was a
monstrous sight even to scp096 its body
was the Red Front engine of an
old-fashioned steam train hoisted off
the ground by four pairs of enormous
black spinley spider-like legs that
propelled the Beast forwards at a
terrifying speed able to move without
the limitations of needing to follow a
railroad track the monster was barreling
towards scp096 with a twisted smile on
its grotesque face at the front of the
locomotive was its circular face with
its unnaturally white eyes and a mouth
that sported rows of razor sharp teeth
all covered in blood this hellish
Abomination a being that was part steam
engine and part giant spider was the
terror of arinum himself the carnivorous
chu chu ch Char seeing Charles racing
towards them on its eight spider legs
would be enough to make anyone freeze up
and stop in their tracks out of sheer
Terror and scp096 was compelled to do
the same except the terrifying train
creature's pale eyes were looking
directly at the shy guy as Charles sized
the anomaly up as its next meal he was
looking at it and that meant scp096
had to kill him the question was how
could it how could the skinny spinley
humanoid hope to even fight something
like cho cho Charles he was much bigger
even more fearsome but as quick as
Charles could move on his spidery legs
he was not faster than scp096 in the
blink of an eye the shy guy raced off
shrieking and sobbing in despair leaving
Charles to continue roaming his island
territory in search of other human
inhabitants to terrorize scp096 had
retreated to some nearby Woods quick
enough to move out of Charles's path
somewhere it could hide for now but the
shy guy could feel a familiar painful
feeling almost pulling him back towards
Cho Chu Charles right back into Harm's
Way scp096 possessed an inescapable
compulsion to kill anyone who looked at
its face and that seemed to include
horrifying part train part spider
hybrids it was a fact of the shy guys's
very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creatures Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try scp096 knew that if it
did then there was little chance it
would survive coming face to train face
with the terror of arinum however while
it was watching Choo Charles from a safe
distance seeing him crawl across the
landscape on his multiple legs that as
CP 096 noticed something it was another
light obscured by the fog but this one
was much higher up one could almost
mistake it for the moon if it wasn't
getting closer all the while accompanied
by the sound of woring rotors while the
shy guy had been evading Cho Chu Charles
the SCP Foundation had been tirelessly
trying to track down its location and
now they'd found their runaway anomaly
here on Aron niram Island as the chopper
carrying the mobile task force Drew
nearer the tyrannical train turned and
took notice to scp096 the foundation's
arrived could have meant a way home and
away from the spidery steam engine but
to Charles the approaching chopper meant
only one thing a new source of food
Captain one of the MTF troops aboard the
chopper called over his headset what is
it do we have eyes on scp096 the captain
replied before realizing what he'd said
well not eyes on because then it would
have jumped up onto the chopper and
killed us all I mean is there any sign
of scp096 on the island negative sir
although you should probably see this
the so replied begrudgingly the captain
unbuckled himself from his seat and
snatched the foundation operatives
binoculars using them to look down at
arinum below it didn't take him long to
spot the massive multi-legged
monstrosity that was Choo Charles who
had fallen still waiting for the chopper
to descend low enough for him to reach
good cravy what on Earth is that thing
the captain exclaimed before taking
another look through the binoculars is
that wait what is an instance of SCP
2086 doing out here SCP 2086 was an
Infamous anomalous species the
foundation had encountered before much
like Charles they were anthropod likee
creatures with multiple long legs that
protruded from a body resembling a
man-made mode of Transport however SCP
286s usually took on the appearance of
buses while in vehicle form sir I I
don't think that's an SCP 2086 the
lookout replied to me it looks more like
an instance of SCP 3023 impossible all
the way out here the captain retorted
we're nowhere near the region where the
anomaly occurs that could have scurried
its way from Germany and taken Nest here
sir the trooper responded yet another
anomaly that Choo Chu Charles bore a
striking resemblance to SCP 3023 was a
rare phenomenon that was known to occur
at random but was limited to a specific
area of central Germany the effect of
this phenomenon caused ordinary everyday
inanimate objects of any shape or size
to suddenly turn into aggressive spiders
sporting eight legs That Grew From
whatever was affected by SCP 3023
perhaps Chuchu Charles was indeed an
instance of SCP 3023 or some distant
evolutionary offshoot of SCP 2086 it was
hard to say for sure the only thing for
sure was that Charles was a man-eating
Beast more so than an Insidious villain
and being so highly territorial he
considered the entire island of arinum
to be his natural habitat and his
hunting ground anything that arrived in
his vicinity was prey to the terrifying
train and his ravenous craving for human
flesh meant he was ready to attack the
descending SCP Foundation Chopper all
right let's go go go the MTF Captain
called to his troops signaling them to
start repelling out of the helicopter
and down to the island keep your
scramble goggles on Max we still need a
recapture 096 but first priority is
taking down this big ugly beast wearing
goggles specifically designed to destroy
the shy guy from their view the team
began ABS selling out of the aircraft
but chuch Chu Charles was already
waiting for them rearing back on its
four back legs the nightmares train
spider swiped at the descending MTF
operatives would first seem like an
instinctive uncoordinated assault
quickly became precise and Relentless
strikes as Charles sliced through some
of the cables the MTF troops were using
to repel down their Lifeline cut the
Unlucky Foundation operatives plummeted
from midair right down towards where the
terror of Aaron niram was waiting for
them to fall a few of the mtfs made it
to the ground alive and immediately
began retaliating against Cho Chu
Charles the gunfire from their weapons
flickered all around the carnivorous
creature but their bullets could barely
chip the red paintwork on his steam
train body dashing towards his helpless
human prey on his many legs Charles
began to Feast then suddenly something
started pulling at one of his huge
spider legs pulling Charles back moments
before he had a chance to claim his
latest victim the captain of the
foundation's MTF it was scp096 having
zipped out of hiding and shrieking
wildly as it used all of its strength to
wrench one of Cho Chu Charles's multiple
limbs angered that it couldn't reach the
MTF Captain the part spider part train
hybrid stomped the leg that was being
pulled in a successful attempt to free
itself from the shy guys's grip but in
the same instant scp096 used its
anomalous speed to reappear in front of
the already angered locomotive monster
with his railroad rage about to reach
its Breaking Point Charles entered into
a Relentless Rampage making quick work
of the leftover MTF troops before
setting his sight squarely on scp096 but
doing that was his biggest mistake now
Cho Chu Charles had seen the shy guy
twice and to the insecure anomaly that
meant Charles had to go traveling faster
than even the multi-legged monstrosity
could perceive scp096
began racing towards Cho Chu Charles's
many legs the shy guy had realized that
it didn't stand a chance of dealing with
the terror of arinum the same way it
handled all the others that had seen its
face so instead it had settled on a new
approach specifically tailored to taking
down the spider legged steam engine one
by one scp096 started knocking Charles's
many legs out from underneath him
effectively tripping him up over and
over again the shy guy moves so quick
that the cumbersome Charles could barely
react in time having one leg after the
other knocked out from beneath him
causing him to Tumble to the ground
normally Choo Cho Charles was smart
enough to retreat if he encountered
something that could fight back if he
was injured badly enough the spider-like
creature would Scuttle out of Harm's Way
in order to heal his wounds but the rage
at being constantly tripped up by scp096
was distracting Charles from the shy
guys's true Ploy with every leg it
knocked out from underneath the spider
steam train scp096 had been gradually
directing Charles towards a nearby Gorge
with a terrifying burst of anomalous
speed the shy guy caused Chucho Chu
Charles to topple over sideways rolling
over himself until he landed upside down
in the bottom of the Rocky Gorge the
multi-legged locomotive monster spindly
legs flailed desperately as he tried to
reposition himself but with no lock
scp096 had managed what first seemed to
be impossible and beaten the Terror of
Aron niram Cho Chu Charles or for now at
least everyone in the Sleepy Mountain
Town had heard stories about the
abandoned mall and the malevolent
creature that lurked in the wreckage
there there had been enough missing
persons cases lost children teenagers
sneaking out to explore and never
returning home Urban explorers who
stumbled out of the darkness disheveled
and traumatized with an eyewitness
account no one wanted to believe there
wasn't anyone left in the surrounding
area willing to set foot in that cursed
place but that didn't stop opportunistic
Out of Towners from paying the
occasional visit especially if they felt
like there was money to be made in those
crumbling corporate walls Grant and
Jason the hosts of upand cominging
investigative reality show ghostly
happenings were two such visitors when
they heard the rumors about an abandoned
Mall haunted by some sort of dark
presence blame for The Disappearance of
local children they packed up their van
picked up their underpaid cameraman
Derek and headed straight for the
infamous building are you sure we're
allowed to be here Derek asked shakely
as he began filming nope Grant answered
cheerfully that's part of the fun Jason
laughed look man this place has been
left to rot by the city no one cares if
we're shooting some footage besides
worry less about the cops and more about
the ghost of the mall Grant grinned ooh
not funny Derek grumbled come on serious
faces we're rolling Jason nudged his
co-host and the two snapped into their
on camera personalities once a bustling
Center of suburban American life this
shopping mall has transformed into a den
of Terror Grant's voice dropped into a
lower register his expression intense
locals swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home something
that doesn't take kindly to trespassers
Jason
a ghost a demon just an urban legend
that's what we're here to find out Grant
pulled out an EMF reader which began
beeping as he turned it on uh there
seems to be a lot of activity in here
already I'm picking up something don't
know if you folks at home can see this
put the meters going crazy Jason
exclaimed it was a fake meter of course
one that they rigged up to beep and
react when Grant press certain hidden
buttons but the audience didn't need to
know that they were tuning in for story
for spectacle
not for the truth if they wanted that
they could flip over to the nature
Channel and watch some lions chasing a
gazelle on this show they were chasing
pure entertainment they continued deeper
into the building taking in the massive
echoey space the dusty storefronts the
beams of rotten wood strewn across the
ground the rats that skittered across
the floor it was the perfect creepy
atmosphere maybe a little too perfect a
little too creepy what was that Derek
practically jumped out of his skin
spinning around to look at something
behind him hey stay on us Grant snapped
I saw something moving back there Derek
insisted it was a rat Jason rolled his
eyes there are tons of them in here
Derek shook his head no it wasn't a rat
it was way too big okay a raccoon then
come on get it together we've been in
way worse locations than this remember
that old tuberculosis Hospital Grant
shuddered God no that was scary this is
nothing well not nothing Jason elbowed
his partner I did a good job scouting
this place right grant was about to
answer when his foot bumped something on
the ground he looked down and saw a
Polaroid camera next to a long empty
water bottle and a small backpack oh man
get a shot of this Derek obliged while
Jason took a closer look this must have
belonged to one of the Urban Explorer
types who came in here he unzipped the
backpack rumaging around hey look photos
tons of them he dumped the pictures out
onto the ground think he got some Spirit
photography done before he bit the dust
well might as well see Grant joined
Jason on the ground sifting through the
photos as Derrik watched anxiously
boring boring dear dog Sunset now wait a
minute he stopped holding up one
specific Polaroid this is the money shot
right here Derek zoom in on this all
three men looked at the picture
illuminated by the camera's light it
showed a tall long limed pale creature
vaguely humanoid in shape but at the
same time distinctly not quite human its
mouth was stretched wide in a wordless
screech its eyes bloodshot and Wild its
long tapered fingers were reaching
towards the camera damn that's spooky
Jason laughed a bit of nervousness
creeping into his voice how do you think
he set this up Grant asked what if it's
real dererk swallowed the lump in his
throat don't be an idiot Grant scoffed
but then from the outside not 100 ft
away they heard a scream ears splitting
loud filled with rage pain and
animalistic Instinct it was like nothing
any of them had ever heard before the
scream was followed by the sound of
splitting wood branches crashing to the
ground and horrifyingly the sound of
something breaking down a nearby wall
what did you do Jason backed away from
the sound me you open the backpack Grant
shot back guys I think we need to get
out of here Derek watched in wide-eyed
Terror as two pale hands ripped a hole
in the wall in front of them making an
opening for that pale hairless head from
the photograph to poke through all three
men prepared prepared to make a break
for it and run for their lives but as
soon as the creature saw them it was
already too late with another scream SC
scp096 sprinted toward them grabbing
each man and throwing them to the ground
the camera shattered into pieces from
the impact and Derek skidded painfully
across the ground as he rolled onto his
side to try and push back up to his feet
he caught a glimpse of the monster
opening its mouth impossibly wide and
descending on his bosses he really
didn't want to focus on what happened
next but suffice to say there was
nothing of them left afterwards Derek
tried his best to escape but he was no
match for the brute strength and speed
of scp096 from the moment he saw its
face his fate was sealed there was no
Escape soon the beeping EMF meter the
scattered photographs and the broken
pieces of the camera were the only thing
left of the crew from ghostly happenings
their devoted fans would never get
another episode but at least one being
in the abandoned Mall could rest easy
now scp096 was safe again no one was
living who had seen its face it slowly
crawled back to the hole it had made in
the wall ready to return to the forest
and climb back up the mountain there it
could curl up beneath a tree and stay
there for as long as it wanted but as
scp096 reached the hole in the wall
where it had once been able to see night
sky stars and the trees in the distance
there was only Blackness it was as if
something dark was stretching over the
opening blocking the outside world from
view 096 reached out a hand to push the
blockage out of the way but whatever it
was slithered away from the touch faster
than the pale hand could move the
wriggling darkness crept back into the
building weaving in and out of the
shadows as scp096 watched it curiously
whatever it was it hadn't looked at the
creature's face yet it wasn't sure if
this thing even had eyes but then
stretching out out of the darkness and
into view was a garish face with wide
white eyes with massive pupils a round
nose and a wide wide mouth stretched
into a toothy Grimace that might have
once looked like a smile this was the
creature that had made the mall its home
the apex predator of this biosphere and
it was staring directly at SCP 96's face
it's face with a shriek 096 flew into a
primal r age clawing at the catlike
creature but before 096 could reach it
the thing was gone where was it where
did it go 096 roared tearing at the
floor ripping up the tile and gouging
long deep scratches in the concrete
beneath a sound in the distance Drew 0
96's attention and it bolted in the
direction of the noise swinging at any
obstacle in its path as it went it
ripped down a banner advertising free
frozen yogurt samples crushed an empty
cell phone kiosk and threw a gumball
machine to the floor with a crash would
rip the entire Mall apart if it had to
if that was what it took to destroy the
being that had caught a glimpse of its
face and disappeared then 096 could see
it that face that wide-eyed grinning
face it sprinted toward the face as fast
as it could the cartoon cat was looking
at 096 not from a place in the room but
from behind the screen of a television
in the El El ronic store window somehow
defying the laws of physics and reality
it had made its way into the TV 096
didn't pause to ponder the logic of this
there was no room for critical thought
there was only the need to shred to
consume to destroy it burst through the
window sending shards of glass in every
direction and reared back to attack the
screen it was so focused on its singular
task that it didn't notice the long
black arm snaking across the floor wind
winding around its feet all of a sudden
096 lost its balance as its legs were
pulled right out from under it those
stretchy arms dragging it into the TV
screen itself when 096 regained
Consciousness it was in a place it did
not recognize gone was the inside of the
mall or the familiar forest and
mountains outside instead scp096 was in
some sort of handdrawn world a massive
house with a hallway that seemed to go
on forever lying with infinite doors
leading to who knew where the floor
tipped and tilted at odd angles and the
geometry made no three-dimensional sense
it was dizzying and deeply off-putting
scp096 had no frame of reference to
compare it to but a human witness might
have noticed that this place looked like
something out of an old cartoon from the
days of Steamboat Willie and the like
scp096 did not think such a thing it
only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
place one that felt threatening though
there were no visible threats and it
knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its
face all along the walls between each
door there were clocks in the shape of
that horrible cat eyes ticking back and
forth with each second wide smile
mocking scp096 as if to say try and find
me scp096 would not be discouraged there
was no room in its mind for that sort of
thing there was was only the singular
goal of finding the cartoon cat and
tearing it limb from rubber Ho's limb
psychological warfare would have no
effect still cartoon cat would give it
his best shot this was his world and he
could do whatever he wanted here cartoon
cat poked his head out through a random
doorway waving to 096 with one of his
puffy white gloved hands as 096 wailed
and began to give Chase cartoon cat
slammed the door shut only to open
another door down down the hall and poke
his head out of that one he did the same
trick over and over jerking scp096
around from end to end of the ever
expanding animated hallway after some
time pass however it appeared scp096 was
not going to get tired and was not going
to give up hope of catching its prey it
was time to end this cartoon cat wrapped
one long arm around s SCP 96's neck
restraining it against the wall and
began to squeeze Tighter and tighter but
nothing happened scp096 did not collapse
did not react at all except to tear out
the arm around its neck until it broke
free then it returned to the Relentless
Pursuit tearing door frames apart
pulling up floorboards punching through
walls every time it dealt damage to the
environment the space filled itself back
in an unseen pen scribbling in the gaps
in the floorboards sealing up the holes
in the walls two powerful beings going
back and forth locked in a seemingly
equal matched battle cartoon cat tried
to destroy scp096 in a myriad of ways he
tried to rip the Beast apart to snap its
neck to do any manner of unspeakable
violent acts it had done before with
great sadistic Glee but this pale
Abomination would not fold would not
break this wasn't going to be any fun if
there was no ending and if 096 kept
destroying one of cartoon cat's favorite
pocket worlds that was quite enough
cartoon cat grabbed hold of 0 96's arms
and legs the creature thrashing
viciously as he did so and threw it into
the blank space just beyond the
Illustrated world back in the mall as CP
096 crashed back to Earth was about to
resume its search for cartoon cat when
suddenly a bright light illuminated its
face a police officer stood a few feet
away holding a flashlight excuse me you
can't be in here you're trespassing the
officer started to warn but his words
were interrupted when 096 began to
scream soon he would be screaming too
there's never a good day for a super
villain attack or a tense Feud with your
closest sibling and for the Mighty Thor
this day was turning out to be both as
the self-proclaimed strongest Avenger
flung his body across the planet Earth
using his trusty Magical Hammer molier
the Asgardian stealed himself for yet
another confrontation with his evil half
brother Loki the god of Mischief as per
usual Loki was terrorizing the humans of
a random City using his Illusions to
manifest imaginary dragons and other
ferocious beasts and what was also usual
is Thor had no idea what his brother's
motive or endgame was all the God of
Thunder knew was that this kind of
trickery dickery would not be stood for
while these terrible creatures weren't
real they were still very frightening to
the earthlings civilians were running
around in every direction away from Loki
and this was causing all kinds of chaos
and traffic disturbances regardless of
what Loki's plan was Thor knew that his
brother had to be stopped before things
escalated further on Earth humans needed
to rely on vehicles to get around and
even the slightest inconvenience in
transportation could lead to disaster
Thor touched down in the same City
Square where Loki was unleashing his
horde of Make-Believe monsters Landing
in a classically cool superhero way
hello brother Thor proclaimed I don't
suppose you'll be stopping this without
a fight Loki smiled a mischievous smile
and replied aror we meet again and once
again you're wrong I can stop this
anytime I want Loki swiftly moved his
hand through the air casting a new spell
to dismiss his diabolical decoys the
Illusions dispersed naturally and soon
the two brothers were facing each other
one-on-one
see Loki chuckled Thor was rightly
confused by his brother's unpredict
ictable actions he pointed molier
towards Loki in an accusatory manner no
Illusions no sorcery what are you really
playing at Loki said Thor and then Loki
reached into his robes and produced an
unusual cube-shaped object as his good
brother was all too aware this
particular Cube was the latest in a long
line of mysterious and Powerful cubes
that Loki had used for his various evil
plans Loki juggled the unknown Cube from
one hand to the other then waved it in
the air and front of Thor and began to
laugh maniacally all I need to do is
open this ancient box of mysteries and
I'll become completely Unstoppable don't
you dare do it Loki Thor shouted that
sort of power will be misused in your
hands that's precisely the point Loki
continued to laugh then reached for what
appeared to be the lid of the cube he
grabbed the top of it and made a show of
beginning to twist this sent Thor's
heroic instincts into high gear and he
threw molier at the cube knocking it out
of Loki's grasp as the cube flew away
from the grinning villain Thor Dove to
retrieve it before his brother had the
chance he soon held the strange item in
one hand while calling mol back to the
other as Thor stared at the cube
pondering its purpose Loki stretched out
his hands in desperation oh no not my
Cube if you open it now my PL is doomed
Loki pleaded Thor responded with a laugh
of his own nice try brother but I'm
going to open it and so the God of
Thunder did Thor popped the Cube's lid
and braced himself for whatever Cosmic
force was about to be released but for
some reason nothing happened still
curious Thor took a cautious look inside
as it turned out the only thing within
this apparently non-magical Cube was
what appeared to be a fully developed
photograph what an Odin's name is this
Thor removed the image and held it close
to his face it appeared to depict an
emaciated pale humanoid with long
spindly limbs standing in the corner of
a a compact room with smooth metal walls
in all his many years traveling the nine
Realms Thor had never seen anything like
it whatever the creature actually was it
certainly did not look happy of course
what Thor was actually looking at was a
photo taken of scp096 inside of its
containment unit at the foundation the
shy guy as its nickname suggested did
not like having its face looked at even
via secondary means such as photography
or video recording the anomalous
humanoid sense of Shame about its own
appearance was so great that a mere
moment after Thor fixed his Asgardian
Eyes Upon its Visage scp096 began to
stir in its containment unit the
creature wailed and covered its face
with both of its hands on its long siney
arms it screamed and carried on for a
duration of 2 minutes after which point
scp096 sprinted towards the steel walls
of its containment unit and smashed
through reaching speeds greater than
most Motor Vehicles scp096 began to zero
in on Thor's location as was always the
case when another being saw its face the
shy guy was compelled to utterly
annihilate the offending Observer with
its bare hands Thor himself had no idea
that scp096 was in route and continued
to squint at the photograph perplexed by
the mysterious entity depict therein
Loki now resumed his mad laughter
because once more he had managed to
trick his foolish brother into falling
for one of his ingenious schemes make
sure to get a goodlook brother Loki
gloated yes look at the full creature
that will bring about your inevitable
destruction Thor was annoyed if you
think that showing me a gross picture of
some lowly wretch will strike fear into
my heart you've truly forgotten what it
means to be an Asgardian save your
sentiments for the halls of Valhalla the
green-clad evildoer cackled you'll be be
there soon enough and with that Loki
used a charm to turn himself invisible
and vanish completely from Thor's sight
Thor stomped his foot on the ground
angrily he wasn't sure how but it seemed
as though Loki had gotten the last laugh
once again Loki he shouted after his
brother come back here and face me with
honor then the God of Thunder sighed
pensively and thought to himself who am
I kidding he's never going to change
Thor looked at his trusty Hammer Mo your
old friend it seems like we've saved the
day yet again shall we away back to
Avengers HQ he then shook Monier up and
down like a puppeteer simulating a nod
Splendid idea Mo you're glad you thought
of it Thor chuckled already in better
spirits that's when he began to hear the
footsteps of scp096 rapidly approaching
him Thor turned his head towards the
sound and saw the same disquieting
Creature from the photograph that was
inside Loki's Cube zooming headlong
towards him with Reckless abandon the
Asgardian blinked he almost couldn't
believe his eyes whatever that thing was
it was faster than Thor could have
possibly anticipated was it looking for
the photograph he wondered hello there
Thor called out as scp096 continued to
make a beine at the Caped superhero the
God of Thunder waved the photograph of
scp096 in the air is this your um selfie
in all likelihood Loki had been his
usual conniving self and stole that
self-portrait from the miserable
creature hoping that would mistake Thor
for the thief the god of Mischief had
probably even used a glamour to disguise
himself as Thor when he did the deed
Thor believed that all he had to do was
clear up this misunderstanding and that
he and this strange Beast could go their
separate ways without coming to blows it
was a naive optimistic and ultimately
incorrect view of the situation but at
least the hero's heart was in the right
place I don't need this so Thor said
trying to reason with the creature you
can have it back if you'd like but
scp096 showed no signs of stopping and
was seemingly enraged even further by
thorf flaunting its decidedly
unflattering photograph the shy guy
kicked the ground and shot forward with
a powerful burst of speed one of its
elongated arms slammed into Thor's face
with enough Force to nearly knock the
Asgardian off his feet Thor was so
surprised that he instinctively whacked
the creature with molier sending scp096
caring backwards down the street it
wasn't launched more than a dozen feet
before for its powerful arms and legs
dug into the pavement and slowed its
velocity to zero even though the thing
from the photo had taken a direct hit
from molier it barely looked phased on a
physical level one thing was for sure
the shy guy was still incredibly
distraught and it was directing all of
those negative emotions towards the God
of Thunder what was this thing what is
this thing Thor wondered to himself it
was fast strong and durable to an une
Earthly degree if this thing wanted to
engage in single combat Thor wouldn't
back down he was an Asgardian Warrior
and sometimes that meant facing
challenges headon no matter how suddenly
they arose still his time with the
Avengers had taught him that having a
clear reason to fight was sometimes even
more important than the fight itself hey
quick question um what are you he said
aloud to the creature scp096 didn't
answer within seconds it was on Thor
again like a bil snipe on another bil
snipe the screaming humanoid swung
wildly pelting its opponent with blow
after blow Thor tried once more to
communicate with his unknown enemy I
have no quarrel with you Weir one Thor
spoke so take your noodle arms and be
gone for all of its Relentless ferocity
the humanoid Abomination left countless
openings that a season Warrior like Thor
could easily exploit of course most
mortal combatants would be unable to
endure the brunt of the shy guys attacks
for long enough but true to his nature
Thor was a God the Avenger struck back
with another crushing blow from molier
aimed straight for the creature's
sternum once again the monster was
pushed back for a moment and then
resumed its maddening Onslaught a blow
like that should have at least busted a
rib or two were the bones of this
horrible thing made of vibranium or some
other rare metal out of the depths of
space Thor realized he was now fighting
on the defensive while he had faced foes
in the past with much greater physical
strength than the shy guy including his
superhero colleague Bruce Banner's mean
green everloving Alter Ego The
Incredible Hulk the sheer tenacity of
scp096 meant that being careless with
his own protection could lead to Thor
taking unnecessary hits that would
eventually wear him down in a prolonged
fight the Ry humanoid certainly didn't
show any signs of slowing down or tiring
even though it had to be expending a lot
of energy to move so quickly between his
alternating deflections and counter
blows against the creature Thor molded
over his brother's words from earlier
Loki was right about one thing this is a
Fel Creature if ever there was one still
as long as there is thunder in my blood
I won't allow a hairless curl like this
to bring me my own destruction think
Thor what would Stark do at a time like
this he says he's the smart one after
all humor him with his highly
sophisticated tactical Acumen that was
similar to Iron Man except for the fact
that it was much better and stronger
Thor efficiently assessed his current
situation while the pale Beast was
undoubtedly violent and far mightier
than most terrestrial creatures its
attention and all the brute strength
that came with it had been fixated
solely on Thor since it arrived in the
city the ASG guardian's best guess as to
why was the photograph that Loki had
tricked him into looking at devious
trickster that he is Loki must have
known that this thing would hunt down
and attempt to pulverize the latest
being to see its face which now of
course happened to be Thor the
revelation of of this fact meant that
Thor no longer had to worry about the
fate of civilians if he chose to
relocate to a less populated Battlefield
since the creature was now guaranteed to
follow him nobody else needed to get
hurt while running from the fight wasn't
exactly the god of Thunder's favorite
strategy it would massively reduce the
chance of collateral damage he'd be
saving lives in classic Avengers fashion
Captain America would be so proud not
that Thor would have done it any
differently even if he didn't have the
Star Spangled mans approved
scp096 leaped in towards Thor to deliver
its next waling strike but the Asgardian
quickly grabbed it by the wrist and
pulled the Ferocious creature off its
feet he lifted it up and over his head
before slamming it down hard into the
pavement with a bit of space between
himself and his anomalous foe Thor began
to swing molier around by its leathery
wrist strap the shy guy desperately
scrambled to its feet to resume the
attack but by that time Thor had already
thrown himself Skyward he soared between
the buildings using the force of mol's
trajectory making it his mission to exit
the city as soon as possible Thor looked
down to see that a CP 096 was following
him along the ground exactly as he
predicted it would while the battle with
the Beast would most certainly continue
the second he dropped back to Earth's
surface he could rest assured that the
place where the Showdown would take
place could be chosen by him he saw an
evergreen forest on a nearby mountain
and decided that it would do nicely as a
place to finish this by I'm sure no one
would mind a few stray bolts of
lightning around here Thor thought the
God of Thunder was amused by the
prospect of going all out against this
being even though it probably had its
reasons for wanting to destroy the one
that saw its face Thor was past the
point of Taking Chances on diplomacy
this distressing creature was after all
an adversary that Loki had plotted to
send after him through one means or
another and because of that it was
likely to have power and guile to spare
Thor breaking a sweat to Vanquish the
thing would be a fitting replacement for
the fight that he would have to have
with Loki Thor's feet hit the ground on
a Stony Mountain ledge and once again he
struck that iconic superhero Landing
pose remarkably the shy guy had kept
pace with Thor almost the entire time
the Asgardian had been flying smashing
through every tree and Boulder that
stood in its path even so Thor was more
than ready for it storm clouds rumbled
overhead the sky above the mountain was
trembling as Thor decided that it was
time to bring down the thunder on his
unfortunate foe boom crack the heavens
flashed with electrical might as Thor
channeled the energy from several
lightning bolts through molier before
unleashing a Consolidated blast of
unbridled power onto scp096 the shy guy
didn't even attempt to dodge as Thor's
thundershock treatment bombarded it with
light and heat the likes of which few
Mortals could withstand Thor released a
second blast then a third surrounding
scp096 with with as much lightning as
these Earthly Skies would offer him
after keeping at this for a while Thor
decided to let up momentarily to check
in on his foe only to see that there
were no signs of visible damage on the
creature it wasn't even slightly singed
the God of Thunder could feel his
brother laughing at him from somewhere
out of sight and Out Of Reach the
Monstrous humanoid in the forest below
was proving to be far more than Thor had
baren for but he was nowhere near ready
to give in and accept defeat still maybe
this was in a fight worth having on
Earth all Thor's electrical attacks were
doing was destroying trees and the
planet was already facing unprecedented
levels of deforestation due to the greed
of human CEOs and Shady entrepreneurs
Thor certainly didn't want to be part of
the problem and now that it was
occurring to him he realized that he
should probably try to do something
about that once the situation with the
shy guy was resolved it didn't matter
how close of a friend Elon Musk was to
Tony Stark these overreaching humans had
to be given a Stern talking to by the
God of Thunder with or without hammer in
his hand of course Thor's
environmentalist concerns had to go on
the back burner for now since scp096 was
advancing towards him once again with no
hint of slowing down let's see if you
can follow me back to Asgard you son of
an elf Thor thought he held his hammer
Aloft and counted on Hemel to deploy the
bifrost the Rainbow Bridge arrived
seconds before scp096 his arms would
have reached the Asgardian and as
expected it instantly carried Thor into
the interdimensional space between his
destinations amidst the swirling sea of
multicolored lights Thor shared a laugh
with nobody but himself and mulier so
much for shy guy said Thor looks like
it'll have to resolve those body issues
on its own time I've been through
something similar so I can relate best
of luck pitiful beast but while Thor was
congratulating himself for his strategic
Retreat he almost didn't notice that his
foe hadn't actually stopped in its
Pursuit as a matter of fact scp096 was
currently inside of the bifrost and
swiftly gaining on the God of Thunder
the shy guy was truly running in the 9s
well 90 mph or more but it made the same
difference the creature grabbed Thor by
his ankles and screeched in mortified
rage Thor punched scp096 in the face
hoping to shake it off but to no avail
the two opponents spun through the by
Frost locked together in an unbreakable
grapple until they collided with the
walls of interdimensional space Thor
knew exactly where this was going and he
wasn't happy about it like a sheet of
ice composed of photons the outer limits
of the bifrost broke away sending both
combatants shooting off into the void
seconds later a wormhole spit Thor and
scp096 out in a vast junkyard filled
with the remains of countless spaceships
and alien life forms great I'm trapped
in this garbage world again I knew I
should have picked somewhere closer Thor
shook off the nauseating effects of the
failed interdimensional trip as C P 096
was already hail and Hardy for another
round Thor grimaced with frustrated
anticipation uh how about a quick
5minute rest Thor implored the shy guy
gentleman struce scp096 roared and
dashed forth more crazy than ever Thor
exhaled in futility I thought not he
whipped molier around and hurled it
straight for SCP 96's skull the reliable
uru steel Hammer made contact knocking
the creature onto its back at the very
least Thor could always count on his
signature weapon to help him out or
could he when the Asgardian tried to
call the hammer back he was shocked to
find that scp096 had somehow grabbed a
hold of its handle even more
surprisingly it now appeared to be
wielding the Hammer as easily as Thor
could son of a you're telling me that
thing is worthy the shy guy now with
molier in hand pounced on Thor Swinging
The Hammer with no technique or finesse
it was everything Thor could do to
Simply avoid the creature's range a blow
from M was enough to cause serious
injury to even the most formidable
Asgardian Warrior damn you molier we
talked about this Thor thundered we're
friends aren't we but none of his words
could get through to the Hammer now that
it was in the hand of scp096 in an act
of righteous Defiance Thor called The
Fury of lightning into his own body this
strange foe which had come from Loki's
latest prank was about to find out what
happened when a god of thunder got
serious with the speed of a lightning
bolt Thor flew at scp096 and punched it
so hard that its grip loosened on molier
for all but a second and that second was
all Thor needed to reclaim his weapon
his hand clung tightly to mol's handle
as he swung the weapon into the Shy
Guy's body with all of his might the
shock wave of this forceful blow
launched piles of debris High into the
air and sent scp096 tumbling across the
surface of the planet like a thrown
piece of discarded food at an Asgardian
Feast with another pulse of electricity
Thor magnetized the portions of the
rubble which contained spaceship parts
and used his manipulation of that same
energy to bury the shy guy in the
deepest heap of trash he could manage
and with one last flick of molier Thor
sent himself hurdling through the
largest wormhole in the sky above and
back into space where it would be far
more difficult for his foe to follow him
finally with some distance Thor breathed
to S of relief you almost had me that
time Loki what an unusual being fought
like a Berserker but was somehow also
pure of heart a kindred spirit to myself
perhaps even so I truly hope to never
meet that thing again now go check out
scp096 versus SCP 343 and SCP 049 cures
scp096 of the pestilence for more
battles with this self-conscious skinny
Legend